before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos while
you're at it guys if you want to be in
the chat the second half of the stream
sign up for our memberships as the
second half of the stream is subscribers
only
also guys follow my instagram it's just
been telling me to plug it
right ish that is correct yeah yeah so
follow my instagram it's just pearly
thing so
today's topic is lizzo is calling but
before we get into that let's let's
introduce our awesome panel today why
doesn't everyone go around say your name
your age your relationship status
and your weight i'm just kidding i'm
just kidding i'm just kidding and where
you're from and where you're from go
ahead um my name is jesse praise or as
people come inside call me the guy with
a shirt um
i am 24 relationship status i'm a man of
god and um
i weigh what 89 kg
i said i'm playing you don't actually
have to say
where i'm from i'm
from england i guess right now
uh my name is fa i'm 29
um i'm from manchester
my name is ellen i'm 28 single from
coventry and
my weight is irrelevant i think she was
joking about the weight thing no i know
she was but i'm just adding i'm hoping
you were joking right
um but no it's your girl tossed high i'm
27.
relationship status complicated
and yeah let's roll uh my name is
ezekiel i'm 21 and i'm single
my name is kit i'm 28 uh i'm single
so
let's talk about today's topic so i
titled this stream lizzo is calling and
on the thumbnail it says leave the
wheels
so um i actually would like to show you
guys a tick tock about this new term we
have in 2022
that is you know
worldwide fat phobia
so ish why don't you show them the tick
tock we're gonna watch
cool cool we'll do okay hold on i'm
gonna show you guys too don't worry
and do the first one
that's on the
microphone
yeah it should it should say like
something like thin privilege
hello
okay
[Music]
having a slight issue with the audio did
you plug it in to the right did you plug
it into the mic or the headphone jack
i've plugged it into the headphone jack
what's the issue
it's not coming up with the option
okay hold on hold on guys
[Music]
i have so many good questions
oh my god
i've spilled my drink a little bit
nobody knows
this is your friendly reminder that the
privilege is real and i know because i
have it let's break it down i've never
been marginalized because of my size
i've never been told my bmi is too high
for a procedure i've never had anybody
look at me funny when i sit next to them
on an airplane or any other public
transportation boys been able to
comfortably sit at seats at restaurants
or in theaters every time i walk into a
clothing store i assume they have my
size i've never gone to a doctor and had
them blame everything on the size of my
body no one has ever said to me you
shouldn't eat that more often i hear i
wish i could eat that i felt like i
didn't get a job because of how i look
with the size of my body never had
anybody make fun of me for moving my
body and makes it feel good and
intersectionality here is key the roots
of fat phobia are inherently racist so
this work isn't just about you or me
it's a movement around dismantling diet
culture and racist so we can all
experience true freedom so thank you for
being here
with your favorite fat bible creators
this is your friendly reminder that the
privilege is real and i know
i think we good okay we're back
okay so my question is
do you think that thin privilege is a
real thing go around no it's not a real
thing all the things she listed is thin
privilege
they're just things that come with the
fact that
you're thin it's not necessarily
privileged if you're fat of course you
know there's certain health um
complications that are going to come so
of course the doctor's going to blame
anything on that your bmi is going to be
over 30 so
that's not a thing that you don't get
because you're you've got thin privilege
it's just the fact
is is there an echo there's the comments
are saying there's an echo i think
there's an echo on the
oh on the video okay okay that's fine
then
um
what do you think
yeah i don't i want to say there's
anything such as uh thin privilege but
there are as you said the
ways people address you speak to you
when you're
when you look maybe extremely different
okay like when you have a certain size
on an airplane you know like she was
saying um but yeah it's it's not
necessarily a privilege it's just i
think society and you know
um
when you're too big you know
that's not the way to go i just think
that's what it is okay um i disagree i
do think there is such a thing as thin
privilege because it's not just about
the extremes of being particularly large
you can be still like a relatively
healthy weight but it's like slightly
bigger and you will definitely be
treated differently like
i i know of people who are maybe like a
size 14 16
and
a friend of mine like returned an item
and the person who was serving her said
well i think this might not have been
your size like you're bigger than that
was she squeezing no she just was
returning it because she didn't like the
item
and and to say it was a poor fit that
doesn't necessarily mean that you don't
fit into that size but as i'm sure we've
probably all experienced
everywhere that you shop and every
garment that you buy
is a is a completely different size like
every retailer works to a different um
that's true
sizing profile
so
that is an example to me of of thin
privilege but if i go to a shop and i
buy a shirt and my friends tell me oh
that looks too small on you you should
have gone a different size
like what what does that mean it doesn't
mean that you know no that's different
but it just means that people are saying
it doesn't it doesn't fit you or it
might not fit
in this particular circumstance that was
a sales advisor saying that to somebody
who's returning an item that's different
to trying something on and your friends
saying oh that's a bit tight on you
but just just advice isn't it like that
might be too small for you she's just
trying to help help out yeah is there a
job i've been a sales assistant you know
you kind of have to tell people does
this fit you does this look good on you
so
fair enough she was returning it and as
a sales person she was probably trying
to convince her to get a different size
oh maybe you might like it then i don't
think it's anything to do with oh that's
fat phobia because
it's just it could just be a fact that
it might look better on you if you try a
different size
because when i hear the word privilege i
think of something that like you're born
with
but but yeah like it's inherent yeah
like like because one one thing that i
often hear is white privilege right and
so that's something that's something
you're born with
right but fat privilege or fat or thin
privilege is a choice
thin privilege isn't a thing if i'm if i
that's my opinion i don't think it's a
thing i think we need to look at the
root
you know definition of the word
privilege when i think of privilege i
think
something
or um a treatment you are afforded
um because of a specific attribute that
you possess so i don't necessarily
believe it has to be something that
you're
um born with i think just the context is
we began to use the word privilege like
white privilege and thin privilege and
things like that
it gives the impression that it's
something that you're born with and
can't change but we have to look at the
root definition of privilege and i think
that's what it is things that you're
afforded because of a certain
characteristic or maybe not even a
characteristic a factor that you possess
whether subconsciously or consciously
fear privilege is not a thing i don't
think it's a thing i don't think it's
anything oh i think especially going
back to that tick tock a lot of the
things that she said that she doesn't
experience because of the nature of the
body shape that she has are just
standard things
are just standard things i don't think
think privilege is a thing i think if we
look at the other end of the extreme
you know like
bigger people that's when we can start
maybe using some of those words but
i don't think that improves the thing um
i'm borderline thin in certain
say cultures or beauty standards and i
don't think it affords me
anything more in my daily life i don't
think you know
so pretty privilege is a yeah that's
what i was going to say i would say
pretty privilege is the thing i mean
yeah even the comments they're talking
about you
listen
i think privilege
how i would define privilege is an
unearned advantage for preferable
treatment
so like
so white privilege yeah you're born with
that so it's kind of like
the
the preference the preferable treatment
you get
is an unearned advantage because you
haven't worked for that preferable
treatment right
but thin privilege if you're slim
that's
you've earned that
so it's not it's not privileged
because
you decided you you ate less you you you
ate less than other women maybe
attacking you obtained is the right word
i was gonna say i do disagree with your
definition of privilege just because you
know if you're rich there's certain
preferential treatment you get from
people but you worked hard to become
rich yes and so i think it's rich
privilege though i think there is yes
there are certain things afforded to you
because you are rich
people treat you differently
would you say somebody is more
privileged if they started from nothing
and became rich or somebody inherited
that richness i don't think there's any
because i could be born poor and then
become a billionaire i'll be very
privileged so i don't think it has
anything to do with that i would say
that i'd change my stance there might be
such a thing as thing privilege but i
don't think it's a bad thing can i ask
what made you change your stance because
i'm thinking about it you know based on
the different initially i was thinking
of definition privilege as something
that you
character that you're characterized as
inherently and it gives you an advantage
in life
but then now i'm thinking of you know
you can work hard and become rich and
become privileged because of it so i
don't think it's necessarily something
that's inherent to you
when i hear privilege i just think of
something you're like born like when i
hear rich privilege i don't think of
someone that was broke and became rich i
think of someone that was born rich yeah
i get what you're saying i get that but
i think it does
being rich does give you a certain
privilege but no matter how hard you
worked for it yeah but when you say
privilege like i think of something you
didn't earn yeah what's the what's the
difference between gaining privilege
because you got to a certain position
and then gaining the perks that come
with that position
so can you rephrase that so what's
what's the difference
right so like for example like if you
say for example oh um you you become the
i don't know let's say you become a
pilot right which means that part of
your privilege as a pilot is you don't
have to go through security when you
travel right okay is that a privilege or
is that a perk that you gained from
gaining a position oh i see the
difference because if you compare to the
park
you can kind of say that being fat
is a privilege now because of as a fat
person you get a privilege of calling
people fat phobic
for privilege i think it is
i think he's right about that because in
certain ways being a um
a marginalized group
can be an advantage right in these days
in this current um
you know yeah but being kind of the
context we're speaking about is um you
know sort of weight what
that let's iron that out
people i'll give you i'll give you an
example
i'll give an
example what lizzo can message someone
like chris evans knowing fully well
everyone knows she has no chance of him
but she can message him why does she
talk to him
why would you why is she messaging chris
evans why would she but this is what i'm
saying like
and then finish
listen to what i'm saying sorry um lizzy
can message someone like chris evans
okay even though most people objectively
know that she doesn't have a chance with
him and he still has to respond nicely
because she's big right when people are
asking them questions um questions about
it in tabloids however on the other
let's say rosa reversed and chris evans
was a really fat man and or really short
and he messaged someone who was
extremely good looking like rihanna
people be like why is this guy in her
dms like that
i think that's i don't think that's to
do with her being fat i just think
that's men and women though
how do you mean like you can't equate
that because yeah the other
what i would say is equal to that is
rick ross
messaging rihanna but he writes
different because exactly the same way
without rich it's just a different
ballgame exactly it's a it's an
exception to the rule hence why lizzo
being fat and rich and got clout is an
exception but women get privileged being
fat oh my god you just gotta no no no no
no i'm gonna i'm gonna show you guys
some tick tocks all you gotta do is
shake your rolls and get a freaking
following
yeah like that's because they're
breaking from the mold they're doing
something that is actually kind of
risque wow that's so brave take off my
clothes and show them my role it's more
like shoehorning i think so maybe not
maybe maybe not brave that sounds quite
i don't know assertive but in a way
because it's the european beauty
standards they are kind of in a way
doing a level of bravery by showing look
at me i look like what the world doesn't
want me to look like essentially so
following is that a privilege sort of
like you get you get you get a reward
for being ugly
okay but this whole thing i think is
more of of um
i think it's more like when the social
constructionists try to
because okay so there are people who
believe that what people like is being
taught to them or being told to them
like people are told what what this is
beautiful this is not beautiful right so
i think those same people um in the
let's say the fat positivity uh
movement
they're trying to
that's their their basic beliefs that
they're they're trying to
uh create
this new form of beauty whereas that's
not how in reality that's not how we
look at things like we instinctively we
know what's beautiful and what's not
right but also why doesn't it
like short men oh absolutely yeah
exactly where's that
where's the broke man positivity
you will you will never have a shout out
one time guys one of the times no sorry
i don't hear anyone shout in that oh
yeah we want men who's more dicks or
anything
you're never gonna i don't hear anyone
saying that so why is that not part of
the positive body positivity and it
wouldn't be a good thing if that existed
i'm not saying it should be a good thing
and i'm not saying that it should be
there but let's not pretend that there's
not
objective truths in the world and
objectively certain things aren't seen
as attractive yeah and other things are
it's a fact so when you try to
um to push a narrative of body
positivity
it should go both ways and always not
just the one that suits you yeah so i
have a question what what would you say
are you european beauty standards and
who is the celebrity that you think of
when you think of european yeah
so we'll talk in
slim thick not even necessarily thin i
think that the beast
yeah slim thick she got tiny waist perky
breasts but she's bottom heavy okay um
little cute button nose
um fair skin type i'm talking into
basically it sort of within my culture
basically is what i'm describing um and
yeah sort of like really
exotic mysterious sort of like features
i would say that's the standard and if
we're really honey on the body though
slim thick back in the day it would have
been like yeah just thin just as thin as
the basis of it but i think nowadays
you've got you know the kim kardashian
and that whole movement and
kardashian isn't you're she's armenian
she is armenian but i do think it's a
whole other conversation yeah i do think
her family and the
narrative that they've pushed on certain
things in terms of beauty and body shape
i think has
hands down had an impact on culture and
body shape and things like that
especially within the black community i
could say that i'm or die on that hill
because that's just true
but i think that that is the european
beauty standards what i've just
described
um but it's just it's just interesting
because when like
based on what you're describing like
you're describing one person and then
you use kim kardashian as an example and
i don't feel like that was who you were
describing
really because i think people are going
for the kim k look at the moment like
yeah
you're you've got two tiny five no
slim thick is a woman who is slim like
slim sort of waist is what i'm trying to
get to to be right slim waist perky
breast and bottom heavy that's why i say
slim thick she's thin and i think it's
the european standard is more blonde
hair blue eyes yeah yeah yeah
i'm not talking about european that's
just what you said earlier
oh yeah yeah
and you know i mean blue white's blonde
hair obviously would be the european
standard but in terms of like standalone
would you say that i don't think that's
the only stunner like i personally don't
think there is one standard because
there are a wide range of women who are
beautiful like like there is a limit
like there's there's too skinny and then
there's there's too fat but there is
there's there's a there's a large
section in the middle where there's all
sorts of beautiful body types so like
yeah adamantly there's there is one
beauty standard like remember we're
talking about the european standard so
if we looked at the catwalk
what is
in europe what do they look at as the
standard of beauty that's weird
i will say when you look at the catwalk
you know what people actually go for
tends to be different to that so
you know yes catwalk when it comes it's
a business they yeah they go for a
specific type of look it doesn't mean
that generally in the wider population
that that's accepted is what's paying
what's nice i think that women put
beauty standards on each other more than
men do i don't think men are that picky
with each other yeah like i think women
women put beauty standards on each other
and are more critical of each other than
men are but paul you know i believe that
it's meant that to us to do that right
because because because you're not
learning no no i'll tell you i'll tell
you i'll tell you why because you're not
correct okay no no because because men
swipe right on dating apps 50 of the
time
meaning 50 of women they swipe right on
so they're not that picky yeah no that's
what i'm saying women's vibrate five
percent of the time of course right
that's that's the whole point is men
aren't that picky
most guys don't even need a girl that's
like super thin she just gotta have a
booty
and they're chilling
no that doesn't i don't think that
correctly you're saying you're saying
that men yeah taught women
right to put high standards on other
women yeah and what was it consciously
but i'm saying the data indicates that
men aren't that picky because if it was
men had really high standards they
wouldn't swipe right 50 of the time on
dating apps but also also when you look
at it when you look at ethnic cultures
like chinese african or anything like
that it's always the moms telling the
daughters oh you're putting them away
you need to lose weight so it's it's not
that that's it it doesn't tend to be the
same
sorry but again i said before that the
certain things that we know are
objective truths and those women know
that the objective truth is that men
tend to like slimmer women they tend to
and so if you're going to make yourself
more
of a desirable female for men then yes
they are going to tell you you need to
lose weight can i quickly dial back to
thin privilege just something i've been
thinking about so for anyone who doesn't
agree that thin privilege is a thing
what do you think about how people
perceive adele how she her weight before
to her weight now good point like so is
she not perceived in a different way is
she not treated differently
but then it's not privileged though it's
more like she's being treated like it's
it's like that's it's the norm right
it's like yeah so so how okay
even while she had a lot of weight on
the you know the body positivity
positivity movement was in there trying
like propping her up and everybody you
know
the movement's been around since like
2012. yeah around for a long time yeah
but 2012 i think is a long time to be
honest but um
so she's lost weight now and people are
praising them but she was also getting a
lot of hate from a lot of the people in
the body positivity movement who were
who looked at her and saw that okay
maybe the method she's trying to send to
other women is not um
uh a good one in that she's losing
weight she is like
that whole movement it's it's just an
agenda like it's like
why not see that this person has worked
in the gym eating eating healthy to lose
weight to make herself look more
attractive and able to make herself look
healthier right wouldn't it be more
positive to say that that would like
that's the positive aspect of her losing
weight right
rather than looking at and saying okay
she's lost weight now a lot of these
girls are going to want to lose weight
as well like what's wrong with but also
obviously sorry to interpret i thought
the body positivity movement um on
the basis of it was the acceptance of
all body types yeah well you can't we
shouldn't like you like yeah but why why
should we accept all body types for
women
because
because because it's unhealthy yeah but
sometimes it's not a choice it's not as
simple as that what do you mean
i said it's not always a choice it's not
a choice what you put in your mouth look
at pictures from the 1950s 1940s 1930s
1920s girls did not look like this
what's the difference it's eating
in countries where there's family it
can't be
in my country
do you see people morbidly obese
okay i think we're being extreme no no
no no it's a good question it's a good
question
because no do you know why i'm asking
because if it was something that comes
about it just happened i didn't choose
to gain this weight you would see it in
countries where people don't have food
yet you don't so what does that say
okay and that's a fair enough point i do
feel like we're being a little extreme
because the girls can i can put on
weight if i just decide to change my
contraception yes but however that's a
choice however not even just that not
just that like let's say you couldn't
you couldn't um choose you have to take
it right usually if you take taking less
calories then you're sorry if you're
taking less if you're burning less more
calories then you're taking in yeah you
will lose weight right so that just
means that you you're not um but i think
the issue what i the issue that i'm
having with what you're saying is that
you're making it heavily seem like it's
a choice you're you're fat because you
want to be because it is
you might not want to be it's a
consequence of your actions yeah like oh
how is it not a consequence of your
actions if you eat more you gain weight
just quickly
i i suffered from an eating disorder for
many years
so when i went to an eating disorder
clinic that was i was surrounded by
people who not only suffered from
anorexia bulimia but also binge eating
disorder and i can tell you for a fact
that is not a choice
yeah no i'm talking about people who are
obese but if you look at them you don't
know what is happening behind the scenes
and that is you can't be obese and have
an eating disorder yes you can it's
binge eating disorder it's well then
you're eating yeah yeah you are eating
but it's emotional
okay okay fine fine fine you could say
they eat too much yes
mental health it's emotional eating okay
do you think that 80 percent of people
in america have binge eating disorder
then
god damn i i do think that probably the
percentage of people in america without
disorder is a lot higher
yeah i'm not saying saying 80 of people
in the in the usa do but i suspect
a lot more people in the usa if you look
at statistics maybe let's look at some
statistics
probably a lot more people in the us do
than in the uk
the obesity um i actually did look this
up so out of the ages of 24 to 25 to 34
23 in the uk are obese
35 are overweight and 42 are normal and
i can't it's so small the underweight
category that i can't even see it so
even in the uk but you can equally have
people who are of a healthy bmi that
actually have a very unhealthy
relationship with food
so yes i mean you can you can have a
good bmi and
eat bad foods yes yeah yeah that's
possible but it's still a choice the
foods you put in your body are a choice
we're trying to make excuses for people
not eating right like we can't keep on
doing that yeah i don't think it's
excuses but i just i can't i don't think
i can agree how heavily we're putting it
on the fact that it's a choice but this
is what i was but this is but this is
what women do like honestly anytime a
man has a standard we shame them for it
and take accountability away from women
no and this is this is i'm not saying
specifically you right but i'm saying in
general like the men say they want thin
girls or in shape girls and then the
body positivity movement comes there's
no but i'm saying there's no there's no
broke man positivity
yeah because it doesn't exist like we
take away accountability from women's
poor choices and even now like when
we're talking about hey it's a choice if
you eat too much and you gain weight
yeah it's like we're taking
accountability away from the woman by
saying it's not a choice but even if it
doesn't happen i'm sorry
even within the context of bodies right
if i'm i was born six foot so i'm i'm
happy i'm good but you were born sick
sorry
genetically i was genetically
predisposed
i was genetically breeding
i was genetically predisposed to be six
foot cool but if i wasn't if i was born
if i was meant to be five foot there is
no one here that would say to me women
should love you anyway women should go
for yourself women should find you
attractive you should you might say that
but most women won't so i think so date
a fat guy
i have
i understand what you're saying you're
like there's some people for example who
might emotionally eat yeah right so
we can we can say we understand why they
made the decisions they did in those
moments right because it may be to cope
with something right right so it's not
saying that we can't have compassion for
why they made those choices by the end
of the day they did make those choices
yes right and that's what they are
worthy of love
no one is saying that they're not no one
is saying that they're not worthy of
love or whether they're certain
privilege is that maybe a thinner woman
would be afraid well here's the thing i
i when it comes to thin privilege i
think it actually comes down to
beauty or attractive privilege because
chances are most people will probably
find you more attractive if you're on
the slimmer side than if you're obese so
you think it's a thing of attractiveness
and pretty privileged little not not
necessarily well being being thin or
being being thin or being slim is a
contributing factor to how attractive
some people find you that's just the way
it is so who okay do you know what so as
pick a celebrity that you would say a
feminist liberty that you would say
you're attracted to that megan good
right if megan good
was a size 20 tomorrow how big is that i
don't know how big it is
that's like older than that
she's obese she's obese okay she's obese
it's affected every part of her from her
knees heads and face everything okay
cool
would that would that suddenly change
your level of attraction to her you just
said it's a contributing factor so of
course yeah because it's not just the
looks it's the self-respect
let me answer your questions
right do you think michael b jordan is
hot yeah right
he's like how would you rate him out of
10 physically seven okay if he hold on
hold on hold on michael b jordan
that's the most controversial thing
you've said a seven yeah a seven you
should have chosen
absolutely if that's not a ten i don't
know
are you telling me yeah yeah if you
became obese yeah yeah you were still
waiting physically
are you saying your attraction to him
would be the same
so him working hard to be in shape
everyone wants to know who you think is
a 10 because the pages
might could be jordan's a seven
dancing
so the one who has the highest standards
yeah is the one that's saying if they
were fat they'd still be necessary
the thing is i just think a lot of times
we lie to like to women that are
overweight and say oh you're still
worthy of love right because it's not
it's not that i say like nobody will
love you but the guys that you want
aren't going to be interested in you
because even bigger girls they don't
want to date bigger guys look at lizzo
you feel that they should
yeah
no i i think i think let's get them the
best results so you can either say a
lose weight that's probably the best way
right if liza lost weight she she'd be
cute like a lot of guys would be
interested then you'll say she's not
cute no not not i mean smash or pass
lizzo guys one two three
yeah okay no no guys guys if she was 120
pounds smash her past lizza one two
three
that's that's then like if she was
issued she would be more attractive yeah
yeah like i'm saying more guys would be
interested i'm not saying everyone but
like but like she could possibly get the
results that she wants right right right
or we could lie to her and say you're
beautiful at any size guys will still be
interested but maybe some but
would you say your issue lies because it
sounds like your issue lies in okay cool
if you're gonna be fat fine but it's
like know it own it and be okay with the
limitations
so i've i have a couple issues with it i
have one the issue that we lie to women
okay so i don't i don't like telling
girls things that aren't true right so
saying like guys will still love you at
any size it's not true
that's not true sometimes some guy
okay okay
guys the guys that you don't want will
want you so you can a guy
any guy that gets a lot of money has a
pretty model on his side
or maybe maybe she might not be a model
but she's ins she's attractive right you
don't see any billionaires with obese
whale wives
so that's that's that's
statements it's not because because a
lot of times but we're talking about
exceptions and not the rule right you
might find a one-off and usually with
the if the rich guy does have a bigger
a bigger girl with him she got him young
and she gave him that loyalty young and
maybe she gained weight later that's so
unfortunate also we're talking about
observable reality we're not just you
know making blacks yeah we're talking
about observable reality we're not
saying that women who are bigger cannot
find love you can however as a result of
the fact that you're you're bigger
your pool of men has become smaller i'm
not denying that but where i have an
issue i'm i'm really not denying that
but where i have an issue is pushing any
narrative that makes it seem like
they're not deserving of the man that
they understand
but they aren't but they aren't you are
delivering it just do the work no no i'm
saying you're not deserving if you're
obese you don't deserve a guy that makes
six figures if you're obese
why because they know because they don't
want you why are we entitled to a man's
time affection and money because i'm big
so what i'm saying is that
you as you were not entitled nobody's
entitled to love you like so i'm not
gonna go to a broke guy and say oh
you're you deserve love i'm gonna say no
get a job
and so on with the girls i'm not going
to say oh you deserve love i'm going to
say look i'm sorry if you want those
guys get on the treadmill
it's it's it's very similar because men
and women are valued for different
things
yeah and so
i wouldn't say unfortunately because
it's a lot easier for a girl to just be
thin and pretty but it's easier and get
a banging body yeah girl what if he has
money and money is very money is money i
would say it's much harder to get money
than to stay in shape yep absolutely
hundred percent so so if a guy if a guy
wants to make 120
pounds right a year i think that's much
harder than losing 50 pounds
okay and so what what i don't like is
lying to women and we coddle them from
bad decisions and we take all the
accountability off of them and keep
allowing them to make bad decisions
instead of instead of telling them the
truth and saying hey if you want this
guy this is the way you can get it
but it's not a lie to tell a bigger
woman that she's beautiful
but here's here's the thing it is
because most of society doesn't see her
as beautiful
and so you could say oh f beauty
standards but we know they exist you you
know who's your prettiest friend
you you guys know you guys know deep
down when you walk into a room you you
know
right now
no i'm saying like
that's true yeah and so you you know who
it is but that doesn't mean that the
bigger girls are not beautiful can i ask
you a question okay what is beauty
someone someone can find them beautiful
i think all we're saying is that it's
it's
it in the observable reality it shows to
be a minority of people but pearl's not
saying that she's i if i'm wrong correct
me i really feel like she's saying oh no
no no honey you're not dessert but the
thing is no one deserves no one
deserves a thing
especially in the dating marketplace you
get what you deserve
right so if you are not so if there is
some if there's somebody
if you are wanting if a man is wanting a
certain kind of woman and he is not
attracting her then he probably hasn't
done the work and done the things where
he deserves that woman because if he did
okay then she would come to him and it's
the same for a woman as well i think i'm
struggling with the word deserve because
i just got to say it guys okay no one's
entitled
who is deserving of love is every single
human being just for being born innately
i feel like innately hitler and that's
what
yeah i think i think i think okay
okay do you know what's going on
i don't disagree with you i don't
disagree with you right let's change it
instead of saying love let's say be
chosen no no i mean love i mean lovely
okay but what i'm trying to say love is
love is very broad right i think nobody
is entitled to be chosen by anyone else
in the world i'm not entitled to be
chosen you're not entitled to be chosen
but i have an entitlement in this world
as a human being to be loved yeah but
you could be loved by your parents
but what if you're not what if you're
not lovable
no i'm serious
that's not true some people are shitty
people yeah i'm sorry
and they're okay maybe i need
as a child sure i think every child
deserves to be loved but some adults are
shitty people oh hundred percent and so
if a child don't deserve love
a bigger child i would actually talk to
the parent because i think it's child
abuse if you're like
yeah no i no i'm serious because that's
the most that's the biggest disadvantage
you can put your kid at and you're in
charge of their food so if you have an
eight-year-old that's obese i'm talking
to the parents
yeah so
um i think the main issue we have here
is um
what we see over and over again is
people who are obese fat out of shape
trying to shame men into one thing in
into into into liking them
and that's the main problem so so let's
say if i was with someone right now
maybe i mean we're not dating like i
just met her right she wasn't on the
larger side i wouldn't be trying to put
her down or anything right i would never
have an issue like announce any issue
with her right but where i might start
to develop issues is when maybe when she
starts to
tell me like
i should love her for who she is like
like it's like as a person you'll find
your you know you're friendly
you know all that stuff but just
on the uh on an attraction level it's
just not there but that when you start
to try and shame me to wanting you like
what you want into being attracted to
you that's just not gonna work
[Music]
attraction is not a choice right it's
it's you are you can't negotiate what
you're attracted to and who you attract
so you wouldn't date a woman solely
because i don't even know
i would say yes but on the flip side on
the flip side
if you went to a man and he wasn't
making the money that you wanted him to
make you give him the time of day
if he's personality banks no
you wouldn't give him a chance
this is what you would do this is what
you would do you would date him and hope
he he gets a job but at some point if he
doesn't get a job or start making the
money you want him to make you're gone
okay you're only gonna you're only gonna
put up with that for so long is that
true is that true is that is that true
yes or no are you gonna date about this
are you gonna are you gonna marry a bomb
the rest of your life i don't know yeah
yeah exactly okay
hold on guys let's just finish yes it's
two different things when it comes to
the size of a woman and
how much money a man make but that's
that's what men value is how a woman
looks and women value how much a man
makes because it's innate in us for a
man for someone to be able to provide
for us at the end of the day no matter
how much money we have and so it's a
harsh reality to understand like men
look at looks they don't care how much
money we have they don't care where we
are at in the totem pole with finances
but they want to be able to look at us
and be like they're presentable and as
women we want to be able to look at our
man and be like maybe yeah we're
attracted to him but does he have the
money does he have the coins that we
need if anything happens he can provide
for me and our family
also on top of that sorry on top of that
you know you you mentioned
that um you know would you so would you
um not date woman solely on the fact
that she she's bigger
the thing is i'm not saying that no man
should date a woman that's big if he
wants a data he should however for me
personally i would not date a woman
that's big because it's not conducive
for the sort of relationship i want
because
inherently if you are bigger that means
there are certain things you haven't
done you know it means
unfortunately it means you haven't
worked it worked out in a gym it means
you haven't watched what you're eating
because there is no as i said you cannot
go to a country with famine and see fat
people that you won't so
for me for the woman that's going to
raise my children i don't want her to
you know teach them that you should just
give in to your
um inhibitions and you know just
lack discipline because it takes
discipline to not get fat and i want
that in a woman i want discipline in
their women because if she's overweight
like that's one area of her life she
doesn't have discipline so it probably
trickles down into other areas so she's
no i'm serious it's typically if you
don't have discipline in one area it
trickles down into other areas the same
way if a guy goes to a job and he's a
bum that trickles into other areas of
his life so with her she might not be
good at spending either she might have a
ton of debt she might be sexually
promiscuous like it takes willpower to
be the thing that men want it's also it
also shows in people who are incredibly
successful because nine times out of ten
they're in very good shape and it's
because they have self-discipline with
their career with their mind with their
body as well but this conversation
started about lizzo she's too successful
and she big no i know i'm not saying you
can't have people who are successful
entertainment is a completely different
thing
no no i'm serious i'm serious
successful no so this is this is what
i'm saying like entertainment is is a
different
sector like let's just entertainment is
not the rest and i'm saying this i'm in
entertainment yeah like
but i i we are not the norm right like
most people have to work their whole
careers to get successful where people
that get fame get success overnight and
they're usually young right also i'm
glad you brought up women investment
banking because i can tell you now i
work for a hedge fund and i've worked
for an investment bank to vote for a
private credit firm i have i am yet to
see a woman who is quite high up is
quite successful and is extremely fat
now you lost me there mate you lost me
there because the two just don't
correlate i hear what you're saying that
the fact that you know in simple terms
yeah it takes a lack of discipline and
self-control to get to
a certain way clearly there's a there's
an issue or lack of control when it
comes to food but i don't think it's
it's fair to just say that
actually you know what i disagree no
it's just come to me now that perhaps it
will seep into other parts of your life
that lack of discipline but i don't
think it's fair to just assume that a
bigger person oh their life just me
why do we always as girls because i see
this a lot it's like oh we can't just
assume right but there's patterns of
behavior with people of course and i
don't have time to get to know everybody
of course and so you're going to assume
at some point of course and it's and
it's based off of
what i have seen right
and i don't think there's anything
inherently wrong with that and that's
and that's how
what perception perception right and i'm
saying so when a man is trying to get to
know a woman of course he's going to
make assumptions based on things that
he's seen and i've talked to men about
this like my friend's husband who's
i think they would deem him as like a
high value guy like he's got the five
whatever things they look for right and
he said there's some fat like fatter
bigger girls that i'm attracted to but i
wouldn't date them because typically
they're very undisciplined interesting
and because you know if if if she's big
in one area that means she's probably
not good with her finances they
typically have debt and it doesn't annoy
me and it doesn't mean it doesn't it
doesn't mean every single one right it
doesn't mean but it's just in general
like typically the guys that go to the
get up early and go to the gym they have
good jobs because they're very
disciplined and bums don't tend to be in
the best shape sure but also i'm trying
to see where we disagree like would you
concede that women are in competition
with each other
or they should be okay
so i would define a successful woman
differently how differently than how
this to find a successful man i think a
successful woman is a woman that can
attract a man that she loves and
respects
and raise a family
and i don't think that's possible if
you're a larger woman because of a man
that you would love and respect
wouldn't date a fat woman it's so it
will be harder so it's like oh i don't i
don't think
i don't think
it's impossible what it is
because women do compete
he might look at her and they might look
at you
and then he and a lot of times nine
times out of ten he's probably choosing
you oh name one successful man that's
with a fat woman
hey jesus but then
i think jenny can you say nine out of
ten
i mean nine out of ten times he's gonna
choose
the woman that he finds more attractive
which would probably be the slimmer one
yeah over the bigger one
so it's not impossible for you just
answered my question from earlier
i was just saying it's not impossible
yeah but like there are too many
attractive girls out here
but this is the reason i literally just
want to say you know i said earlier that
um men are the gay people society
they're the ones that pick women against
each other that's why what no no no no
no but here here's here's the thing
here's the thing
it's a very small percentage of men that
are sleeping with all the girls right no
i'm serious because if you ask 100 of
women who they want they list 20 of men
like you want a guy over 6 foot that's
15 percent of men you want a guy that
makes over 80 thousand dollars 70 000 i
don't know what that is here the
conversion yeah it's a small percentage
of men right
and if he's good looking on top of that
even smaller percentage of men yeah yeah
that's what i'm saying so
those guys get their pick of the litter
and they dictate so what is attractive
and and the value that they the market
so no so the market dictates that yeah
but i'm saying those guys pick the thin
girls and then there's 80 percent of men
that are like give me anybody
that's what i'm saying but the girls are
just mad they can't get the top
percentage of guys but when when it
comes down to it they don't deserve them
that's like saying that's like me going
up to a guy and saying oh you don't
deserve a supermodel nobody would care
and then these girls they're they're
whales and they're saying i deserve a
high value guy this is so dangerous guys
because these were saying that there's a
direct correlation between your value as
a woman and how much no we're talking
we're talking about the sexual we're
talking about the sexual we're talking
about the sexual marketplace right so
we're talking about supply and demand
you're you're more in demand because
you're thin that's so sad if you were
it's not sad it's because you took
choices to get there so if you were 300
pounds okay i've just had a baby not too
not too long ago right my son's two now
obviously i'm back to that sort of
pre-pregnancy weight but shortly after i
was quite big you probably had less
options then i was yeah i'm mad
i've been fatter and i had less options
what did you have to get to that what
did you do to get back to that
pre-pregnancy what did i tell you
off-camera
um
but you you you chose to get back to
that you could have just been like ah
i'm at the point of reason i'm even
bringing this up is because it was
nothing to do with i want to increase my
value so men want me it was nothing to
do with that but let's just because it
has offer
relationships
yeah like that's fine that's fine but a
byproduct of you getting slimmer yeah
what do you mean you want me
that word that certainly
disagree that men are the ones that are
creating the rules okay okay hold on
hold on let me let me let me you're
literally saying that do you have you
you you might do now right mm-hmm do you
have guys multiple guys who might want
you right okay yeah uh-huh okay so if
they want you they have to compete to
get you right against each other yeah
yeah but someone's spoken hold up is
how do guys do that how do they put them
in a room and be like fine i never once
said no of course that i never once said
consciously you both literally i think
i've answered that question okay
and orchestrating the market no no no no
no no they're not all it is is that men
will choose right if you're the girl
that he's most desired to say if you all
suddenly started dating women over a
certain size right but what are you
doing
yeah and if all girls started dating
girl if all girls started in guys who
are broke that would be the exact thing
but it's not that but why not the same
thing why you would never fight old man
they think it would never happen
but why are but what you're saying the
same like women do the same thing women
dictate the market too i'm just joking
very well i know that women
we do that but i feel like it's
different because money is the comment
like listen money is the commodity
that's needed that there's no choice in
that one in it i'm not dating a broke
man because i'm sorry no no no but
historically like they're attracted to
good genes that's what's needed exactly
oh you're going to say the hips argument
that no i'm not going women it's not
actually no i wasn't talking about the
hips argument
i was saying men are biologically
predispositioned to like thinner women
why because it's better genes it's
better offspring if a woman's overweight
her chance of an unhealthy pregnancy is
higher
which i think is common sense right if
you're out of shape and you're unhealthy
odds are man say that's the reason oh no
i won't think well it's not it's not a
conscious i don't think it's always a
conscious thing with men some for some
men it is right
but
they can't help what they're
biologically attracted to the same way
they can't help if they're attracted to
a girl with a lower body count you think
it's because they're but look at the
words you just said they're biologically
attracted to you don't think
environmental environmental factors
do you think environmental factors
affect your desire for men that have
wealth or men that are taught but that
isn't true that isn't true but that
isn't true i don't actually because you
have to be attractive like let's let's
keep it right i don't know
you have to have guys you have to talk
one at a time please you have to have
sex you have a sexual relationship and
if a woman is overweight that greatly
affects
that ability to have a healthy
relationship in that respect but being
overweight in like makes you unable to
have sex with a woman isn't it no he
never said that oh they'll smash they
won't wife probably does that
differently
they'll no no they'll they'll smash they
won't wife
they'll they'll smash like you probably
heard like men will smash anything like
you you've probably heard that a
thousand times all right well have you
asked yourself why
like
i think it's fine and it's okay for you
to have a preference over what size a
woman is based on what you're attracted
to because there are men who are
attracted to larger women yeah like i
know of men that that is their
preference and that's fine and i
understand that being a bigger woman
will naturally make your pool of men
smaller
that's understandable and i know i've
mentioned this earlier but i honestly
just think
nobody understands particularly for a
woman and this is not me making excuses
for bigger women but emotional eating is
such a big thing like and to say that a
woman is then not deserving of love or
attention from a man because of that
like i think firstly i need to disagree
with that notion that there are men
that specifically like larger women only
they're wrong i don't think i think men
that say that they have a preference for
that really just can't attract women
that
if that's true why don't you see the men
with all of the options picking the
bigger women as soon as those guys get
money they're like you know what
i'm into models now but look at the
power of what you said about the story
of your your friend and your friend's
husband right he admittedly said there
are certain bigger women that he would
or is attracted to but wouldn't for xyz
reason
isn't that the reason i mean i think
what he was saying is like more mid-size
he would never he would never go for
like an obese chick but there's some
like yeah you know like men are
different they're kind of attract
they're attracted to like body parts
like legs yeah you don't even like
they're just and men will have like
sarah always says men will have sex with
a hole in the wall like
yeah but i've heard guys say things like
oh she was better than my hand
yeah this is
no can i ask you a question would you um
would you date a guy who's obese
[Music]
i would i would and i would and he's
broke and he's broke he's you know why
why you got ginger okay so okay
okay because here's the thing right if a
guy's broke are you going to give him
the time and patience to be explain to
me let me understand why you're in this
position or you're just going to be like
no it's not the reason why i feel like
the two that you can't keep bringing
that into the arguments because it's not
my fault that the the society and the
world uses money as as a commodity as a
means to an end it's not my fault if it
was different then maybe i wouldn't
necessarily need a man that has money
the reason why i would say an obese man
is because one you can lose that [ __ ]
and two
because
it's it should be putting him on the
treadmill
so here's the thing so you said you said
it's not yours i understand about the
money thing um do you make your own
money so why do you need a man to make
money
as simple as that question is why do i
need a man to make money you said you
said right you're like oh well the whole
broke thing i can't do that because the
world revolves around it but you make
your own money right okay so why do you
need why does it matter if a man's broke
it's so annoying but um it does you
don't want to be funding for him as well
it does matter no no i can answer your
question the reason why it matters yeah
i can answer your question as to why it
matters unconnected to me it matters
because no no i want it connected to you
uh-oh okay we'll hear my answer there
because
i feel like again you guys have done
this masculinity is tied to it i don't
need him to feel less than i don't need
him to feel less than a man so if you
having money is gonna sort of position
you where you need to be in life
and
you're rejecting a broke man for his
benefit so he doesn't know their stuff
that answers what you just said was
meant to
yeah it's going to influence how you
engage with me it's going to affect my
femininity okay can i just say that
you're not having money it will i'm
rejecting fatal women because i go to
the gym and i don't want her to feel
insecure about it
the real answer is and you know it deep
down in you right it's it's it's
biological tell me you're you're you're
looking for security right right that's
just the bottom line yeah but but you
see no no no one is telling you you
should look for security in the man you
naturally biologically that's what
you're looking for which is why you
would be unattracted to a man with that
who would it be unattracted to you if
you okay if he was obese and he was
broke would you even give him the time
of day
no but see you need you guys need to
understand you're putting two factors in
there i'm just saying
just say he's broke okay just broke just
broke but like good looking
all that stuff no he's he's broke he
lives at home he's good looking but he's
broke
his personality banks
sure
but he's always going to be broke he'll
never not be broke no never you would
not go in there
okay nobody's cool
because of what she just said i've
stopped dating men based on my attention
but that's that's what i said that's
what i said earlier though you would
only date a broke guy if you thought he
could make money later yeah you would
never date a broke guy that you knew was
going to be broken okay but okay wait do
you know what guys i don't think they're
too correlates weight and and you just
said it's easier to
to make money
no i said it i said it's easier to lose
weight than it is to make money right
okay can i ask you a question if since
you're saying that it's different would
you remember a man who's obese would i
marry a man would you marry a man who's
obese if i love him yeah but what does
that mean what would it take for you to
love him
i would not i would not see and this is
the thing this is this is the thing i'm
not understanding why there's a
disconnect between us because
you wouldn't either but yet you're
expecting men to be like you know what
because his weight has no bearings on
whether me and my child eat that day or
not him his money you know his pockets
being dragged he does could you repeat
that again
his weight has no bearings on whether me
and my child eat or not whether my child
is able to go to school or whether am i
able to buy a car him have not having
money does have bearing on this so
you're not attracted to him and he just
wanted for his money no that's not what
i'm saying i'm saying him being obese
has no bearings on whether i can pay my
bills or not it just doesn't okay but
that's him not working and being a
brokey in life but that's for you
however for a lot of men
her being attractive
counts for them and so they might not go
for a woman they find unattractive and a
lot of times unfortunately that happens
to do with their way so for a lot but
not i think the but i know the thing
that bothers me is it's not for all it's
not a rule of thumb for everyone i agree
with you because if you go to if you're
going to
can you can you tell us why let finish
that video sorry
yeah i was just saying i personally
would not want to [ __ ] obese guy but
that's a personal preference there are
some girls that that would not phase
them that wouldn't be something that
they consider when they meet a guy or
look for somebody that they're going to
marry because
so many other things on their priority
list are far more important than weights
that's the minority
that's women though that's not men
but even that that's the minority of
people like we cannot use that too i
think it depends where you are i think
it depends where you are because go to
go to certain african countries or even
jamaica a good example you know or
specifically nigeria i know that when a
man is getting married to a woman the
woman goes to live with the man's family
and they feed her because it's seen as a
sign of wealth and it's attractive and
so in certain certain markets
it's you know you can be that way and
people will love you
unfortunately and this is the standard
here so i'm not saying it's every man on
the on this earth however in the market
you're in you have to compete and if
that means losing weight lose weight
the controllers man men
this is the thing the market for men we
want women we have to do what women want
so we have to get money we have to be
attractive physically we have to be able
to speak to women
you have to do all those things if
you're short unfortunately it's p you
know it's just it's peaking a lot a lot
a lot i've got no goals to go to the gym
and like make something of it though but
that's the thing you can go to gym and
do that but if you decide no a woman
should love me just for the fact that
i'm short wish they should i'm not
saying no no i'm not saying they
shouldn't
agree
but i'm saying a lot of women won't and
so it's not good for me to just be like
accept it and be like no they should
come and accept me
you can't change your heights of course
which is compensate yeah right you can't
they can't change their height women can
change their weight and that's that's
the thing like men always get shamed for
having a standard
women don't we can say anything we can
say men ain't [ __ ] we can say matter
trash we can say i don't date short guys
i don't date fat guys i don't date broke
guys nobody bats an eye but if a man
says i don't want a girl with a kid i
don't want a girl that's obese i don't
want a girl that is ugly
people are up in arms and then we have
body positivity [ __ ] shaming i don't
want to hoe because men are so oh with
it
what do you mean they're uh with it
girls are out with it well there are
songs written about it because men i
don't want no scratch like what no
what if there was a hit song called i
don't want no fat chicks like it would
not be the same they couldn't do it they
couldn't make number one yeah that's
what i'm saying but a girl but a but a
girl can say i don't want no scrubs and
that's that's a that's a bop i mean
don't give me i'll shimmy to it all
right it's a bop no i'm disagreeing with
that i'm not disagreeing with you that
men do get shamed for their prayer
but what i'm saying is that
i don't disagree yeah men do get shamed
for it but i'm saying it's because their
preferences if that's the word we're
gonna use has bearings on things okay
what do you mean what do you mean when
you say that okay cool for the example
that you just gave like if a man said i
don't wanna date a girl with kids i
don't wanna know
cool going back to what we were just
discussing men control the market is my
belief so
naturally their preferences their
beliefs where they place value is going
to have bearings on the market i'm in
the market
well when we say it we don't really have
that much control no but we do we do we
do we do guys guys we we do we do
because we haven't
no we we we are in control of sex and in
2022 sex tends to come before
relationships
so
knowing that
in a way we're in control of
relationships women control who they
sleep with so in a way women are in
control of the market i mean you could
argue right that a small i could see the
argument that a small percentage of men
control the market but women are way
more influential than men you really
believe that yeah i mean we we
in dating solely in dating nothing else
yeah because because if women if women
the reason okay the reason a lot of
women say that men are trash right is
because they've been ran through right
it's like a bunch of five sixes they've
been ran through by the eight nines and
tens that are never gonna wife them
never they're never gonna give them the
time of day right and so they they come
out saying men are trash but men would
act better if women weren't sleeping
with them but i didn't disagree yeah so
so we're in control of that like why
would he take why would he take you on a
date if you're sleeping him sleeping
with him without him taking you on a
date so like a really like a really big
thing right like for a lot of girls a
lot of modern women's biggest issue is
that most men don't want to commit or
most men they deal with don't want to
commit nowadays right men commit less
today than i did before but that's
because women are freely having sex
outside of commitment whereas back in
the day when the girl when the woman was
like i'm not going to have sex with you
until i see everyone on this finger
that was the incentive for men to get
married and that's why men did it
so
but what we're trying to say is that
when it comes to a day to market it is
actually women who have the power
because women are the choosers did you
know and actually check this as well um
uh but i heard like a stat that you know
only 40 percent of men have ever
reproduced
i've heard that too only 40 of men right
where it's like above 90 of women
because women choose who they have sex
with women choose this is why
competition amongst men right the
masculine competition mate
competition starts at conception what's
conception is one egg
and millions of sperm competing for one
egg fair enough right it has always been
men competing to get sexual access to
women right and it is women who set the
standard of the market it's always been
that way what's happened now is when it
comes to sex
women have much lower standards so men
are like well i don't have to bring more
standards because the the standards are
so low you're saying women were the
choosers yeah women have always been
choosing okay so then you got so okay
i'm glad you agreed so would you agree
that men aren't the hunters dead i
thought that that's the basis what men
believe that i can hunt you but if you
don't pick me i can't do anything yeah a
guy a guy can compete for a woman but at
the end of the day she has to accept him
or else he's going to prison yeah
it's like
i can hunt you as long as long as i want
but if you don't pick me i'm going to
prison if i carry on doing something
that's though going back to what you
said about you know minimizing
responsibility on women for making
certain decisions i've i don't know and
i really don't want anyone to think that
i'm some bitter woman that i've just got
it out for me because i don't i truly
believe in what i'm saying that like i
believe it's the other way round okay
okay can i can i have an example
come back to me okay the thing is the
thing is i'm really struggling to
understand why we'll fix you know why
we're fixating on people who don't not
you specifically who don't want you
because for me i've grown up knowing
certain people are going to find me
attractive other people won't we move
but yeah me saying i wouldn't date a fat
girl there's probably going to be people
people be like oh i wouldn't date you
anyway oh you're trash with this you're
that it's like why are you getting mad
if someone does if someone doesn't want
you if someone doesn't want you move on
and go to who does want you you don't
that's there it's not that deep of a
thing just go for who wants you can ask
a question and then you said earlier you
wouldn't uh date a guy's obese correct
why
um
[Music]
i i am somebody who does place
importance on fitness like that is
something that is important to me as a
person in how i operate in my life like
i love going to the gym i love
exercising so that's something i want to
be able to enjoy with that person
um and just in terms of physically what
i am attracted to yeah i am more
attracted to somebody who
who is into their fitness and so then
you think
so you know what you were saying earlier
about emotional eating and that's a real
thing right yeah so
would you not have compassion for the
obese guy who's into you yeah i would
but it's just not somebody that i
personally want to hold in your
compassion for attractiveness but like
but you know how you but you know how
you're like oh well you know we should
like men should give bigger women a
chance because it may not be their fault
right so i'm saying
why would you not give a bigger man a
chance if it's not his fault i i
completely hear what you're saying but
the point i was trying to make earlier
was that
it's not necessarily a choice being
obese whether you are a man or a woman
is not necessarily a choice and i fully
believe in that because i've seen people
who but don't you think what percentage
is on the time
what percentage of the time would you
say it's their choice in your opinion
that's a great question
somebody
it's not a choice for a couple of the
people who are fat and obese because
they have some disorder or something
right but you keep on bringing that up
so i want to know in your opinion
how what percentage just just spare
numbers
what percentage of people out there
would you say have that disorder it's
not just necessarily
going as far as saying it's a disorder
but emotional eating in itself i think
probably impacts like 40 percent of
obesity i think that would be that would
be my completely random so just
so just
just back on that so
even though you recognize that a guy may
be big and it's not his choice you would
still reject him
yeah because that's not my personal
preference or that's not something that
i would be into so here's the thing if
you can understand that for you yeah
can you not understand that for the
majority of men yeah but um what i'm
saying is that because a woman might be
bigger that doesn't mean she's not
deserving of love because that's what
pearl was saying earlier she's not
deserving of love because she's fat
no no no i didn't say that i said she
doesn't deserve love from the top guys
that is what i said i understood you
were saying and i said and i said fat
and i said fat women they shoot
themselves in the foot because they
don't want fat men
and so yeah and so i'm saying she they
don't get love because the guys that
they want don't want them yeah but but
no i i agree that being a bigger woman
or even a bigger man makes your pool of
people that are interested in you a lot
smaller i agree with that but
but i don't agree that it's always a
choice but shall we
extract the difference between okay so
there is your personal value and then
there's your sexual value so we're not
saying
if you're fat you're not deserving of of
love as a person right as a person yes
yeah obviously you need to be everyone
you know a lot of people you don't have
to be paying someone because of their
how they look like right but when it
comes to sexual attraction
your value when you're obese is going to
be much lower than someone else who is
much healthier that's always saying so
so so even that person who's whose
sexual value is lower
can still be loved in their personal
life but generally just not sexually
about them yeah that you just described
what are these top men bear in mind over
time i think anything that happens
that has an effect in society and
culture it's over time that it happens
what if over time these top men quote
unquote changed where they placed their
value he knows where i'm going with this
change where they placed their value and
suddenly suddenly there was a spike in
how many
bigger women they dated what would
this has happened though because
nowadays you literally described it
earlier right that the beauty standard
now
right is curvaceous woman that didn't
used to be the standard at all the
standard used to be
slim
straight down right and a big reason why
it's changed is because in hip-hop
culture has become mainstream so
anything that's that's admired about
hip-hop has now become part of the
mainstream standard right right
so now all the quote-unquote high-value
men
are picking these type of women like kim
k so now every girl wants to have boobs
every girl wants to have a bomb
every girl wants to have a tiny waist
right like my man over there was saying
like
yes models are still a thing
but actually for the commercial
especially for the new generation for
most that's not the beauty standard that
most people
of our generation are choosing now well
that's we're not talking fashion
standard beauty standard when i think of
that i think very much within the people
and communities what dictates it not
necessarily like in the fashion world
and high fashion the culture does the
cultivators yeah the cultural standard
now it's bbl bbo
bbl to sleep with bbl bbl to sleep with
not to wife i've asked so many guys this
question
no they they like they like a bbl for
the night you know to entertain them for
a little bit they're not trying to wife
a girl with a bbl yeah i think i think
you need to strike more people's actual
choices and what they're actually doing
rather than what they say because you
know a guy might say he likes a girl of
a big bum and that might be might come
under that and they might like a girl
who likes and nails them but then what
are they marrying are they marrying
women who have bbos
on no yeah who's got the rank exactly
marrying girls who have fake nails and
fake hair and fake everything no so i
think you have to look at it differently
but also
when we're you know
everyone keeps bringing up well not
everyone people keep bringing up the
whole uh they deserve love and things
like that i don't think anyone is
entitled to find a partner no one isn't
there there is no soul mate that's true
no one is entitled to have to have a
partner
so i'm i'm right now i'm making
statements about men and women not just
fat women or whatever if you're if
you're fat i think generally or
unhealthy i think you should try to lose
weight to get to get a healthy weight if
you're if you're too skinny you should
try to gain weight to get a healthy
weight i think personally i know it
could be harder
just making blanket statements so i i
don't understand
why we're finding it so hard because
especially um i think ellie you said
sorry ellen ellen sorry ellen you were
you were saying that you know
before you were mentioning people who
have um eating disorders but yet you
were holding
men to a higher standard than you do
yourself because you wouldn't date a
person who's fat you wouldn't
necessarily understand why they're fat
and be like you know what they're fat
but i i might as well give them a chance
you wouldn't do that but you're
expecting men to do that and i don't
understand why right but it's a man's
personal preference too i'm not and i'm
not saying that i would expect all men
to do that but i know there are men who
are more attracted to bigger women and
that's okay and it's also okay not to be
attracted to bigger women it's okay
they're allowed to be but it's just i'm
just being honest when i say in general
men aren't and when men men have all the
options that's not who they pick they
might pick a girl with boobs a butt as
opposed to a stick thin girl right and
some guys still pick the stick thing
girls right it doesn't
but they are not picking obese women big
women at large it's the same it's the
same as there are
a a small exception of women
who would choose a man who doesn't bring
financials to the table because they
like to be in control the majority of
women will not choose that man but there
are an exception that will choose that
man so i think yeah there are exceptions
there are exceptions there will be some
men where that is their preference fine
right
but when we're talking we're talking
generalities in terms of dating dynamics
and dating marketplace the majority of
men are going to choose well the
majority men are more attracted to women
on the smaller side than the bigger side
whether that's fair to say or not it's
just the way it is
okay i'm going to take a second and read
super chats
okay guys i'm sorry i know it took a
little bit to read these i i saw the
last super chat in the chat i know y'all
calling me out
okay so two dollar super chat um from
randy constance big girls need love too
craig friday joke boy type over an hour
and no super chat's red really pearl i'm
sorry okay i'm sorry we're on a roll
courtney harris she said that she can't
be with a broke guy because he can't
afford life expenses so why not earn
more so you can afford to love broke
guys stop capping
sentience biologically amidst other stat
states points one of the biggest points
one of the points that are missed is
that bigger women also have more issues
for pregnancies just as women only value
a men's addois physique men prefer
slimmer women the uk economist ask your
female guests would they prefer their
son to marry an unhealthy obese woman or
a slin slim healthy woman oh i'm going
to take a shot what do you think
fair question yeah a slimmer woman
summer i think it's a stupid question
but a slimmer woman
okay
monkey u-s-o-p-p
hey black girl in the middle if you're
fighting for these bigger women then get
big and tell your daughter she should
get big if you're not then you then you
know the truth miss me with the
non-accountability
matt busher um not iq shaming but the
lady on the left screen lacks depth of
thought
sentience men
men value fit feminine and fertile
faithful and family-minded men will
easily take a six with those over a body
all day every day and twice on sunday
notice women's money and achievements
were never mentioned caius super chat
thank you so much sentience stop dessert
stop the deserving bs nobody deserves
anything people earn what they get you
can argue children deserve slash need
parental love for growth but there is no
entitlement for romantic love these
entitlements these days is unnecessary
unrealistically unhealthy triple t
studios if women's or women are all
tense they'd all be average women lazy
artists i want to shoot my shot at the
black queen in the middle but apparently
michael b jordan is a seven so i must i
must be under the scale oh loosely lucy
manny f hi pearl ask the females if they
would give a chance if they were
um wait uh hi pearl ask the females that
if they would give a guy a chance if
they were 5 10 280 pounds 40 body fat no
capping
i mean i've already mentioned about the
weight but my ex was five foot seven if
that means you did charity work
and we went together
no no no okay i just want a quick quick
question what if what if he said he
dated a girl that was 250 and i and i
said oh you did charity work would that
be
it would cool
do you know what actually it would be
love a war boy so it would be a fair
thing to think but
you don't have that energy when it comes
to fat women
you don't have the energy
yeah
canon 11t i have a cigarette smoking
disorder info vader greedy powers of the
world want to keep all of us clueless
about how modern diets have caused a
vast majority of our health problems
including these weight conditions people
used to defend obesity dug mpa
body positivity started in the mid 2000s
it was meant to come combat the negative
image of an eye patch a missing arm and
something that you can't control fat
people took it over and ran with it
caloric deficit lose weight boy type
it's science calor calorie surplus
equals weight gain calorie deficit
equals weight loss literally she is
arguing the laws of thermo
thermodynamics so delusional daniel a i
am tired of people using the excuse of
european beauty standards when the whole
of africa with the exception of south
africa and egypt have a lower bmi than
the whole all whole of europe and the
usa it's lazy excuses zero
accountability salon feed a hundred
dollar super chat we're gonna do a
little
[Music]
thank you so much this is our stream
sponsor okay salon
freddell
no rich man wants a western women i'm 60
years old very fit wealthy a rotation of
30 hot young women foreign and usa women
usa women are very overweight matt
butcher everyone gets judged and treated
better or worse for literally a thousand
different reasons coming from a thousand
different sources everyone say sig fried
even men at the lower end of the
financial ladder who lean towards
chunkier women don't like whales alice
aleister horton here's a privilege the
fact that this is the only the second
channel i have subscribed to in 10 plus
years consider yourself lucky pearl
thank you by the way hit that like
button while you're here subscribe to
the channel
yeah okay
info vader people don't realize it's
called female privilege privilege is
invisible to those who have it asante
kojo thanks pro for giving good good
content like this all the time walton
rich morgan obesity is the reason for
health conditions miss thin privilege
just wants to keep her competitive edge
she doesn't care about those whales ata
i was raised to be respectful and a
reasonable man and was not taught how to
vet women to find out if they were going
to be an amber herder jada pinkett
i suffer for not knowing those lessons
but teresa o'neil would say happy wife
miserable man happy man happy
relationship of those from the last show
okay let me do refresh it just to make
sure there aren't any more also guys
sign up for memberships if you want to
be a part of the chat i know some of you
are salty that i've turned on members
only chat but we're trying to get ish a
camera do you guys want to know what ish
looks like let's go you want to see he's
a good looking guy right ladies and
gentlemen he's beautiful we're trying
we're trying yeah yeah so does he get no
he's cute
good good looking guy you want to see
what he looks like let's get him a
camera
um also guys like the video it really
really helps with the algorithm how many
people we got in here right now oh you
got one thousand eight hundred do we
have do we have fifty percent like ratio
on that i don't think so we need five i
don't i don't think so let's see if that
fifty percent like ratio okay joseph
seven one three that big ass gap tooth
and bushwick faces charity work the uk
economist he was there for true good he
was triggered and they always are
defense no offense guys love you keep
sending money
um
the uk economist would be interesting to
know what type of man based on his
income your guests feel they deserve and
qualify for sentience pearl here's some
money to learn to read the super chats
properly unh
i'm doing the best that i can
aisha examines health is the point
healthiness is attractive to all human
beings slim waste reduces your chances
for heart related problems for men and
for women
ryda how come women can't understand
generalities they always have to
personalize things dragon stallion 1001
findings reveal that approximately
one-fifth of all u.s adults
report emotional eating while 42 percent
of u.s population falls within the obese
category if they know they eat
emotionally get psychological
help okay good let me just also guys
also guys
follow my instagram it's just been
telling me to plug my instagram it's
just dot pearly thanks
um and then
marcus moore sorry just to remind
everyone that every that we saw ish on
the 24-hour live stream stop it stop it
stop it we're going to go back together
24 hours you know two videos you don't
watch that yeah yeah it's too long don't
go through it frankie costello i would
like to talk more about the problems
with the current food climate screw your
hoa grow corn in your front yard and
make a community
composter okay
so
we are going to react
to the next video so
let me
pull it up on my phone
so i have another video
um and we're gonna do do the one with
khloe kardashian it should be the third
look at it
so okay so i'm gonna show you guys i
can't stand people that are like
okay i can't stand people that are like
eating a bucket of like hog and dust
people that are like eating a bucket of
like panda dust ice cream
and like they won't work out they won't
change their diet they won't drink more
water they want whatever but they're
complaining completely complaining
but they're complaining
[Music]
there is so much wrong with this here
are three things that come to mind as to
why this is absolutely disgusting one
she's spewing this rhetoric that people
in larger bodies just sit around eating
ice cream all day one that's not true
and number two who are you to judge if
somebody does or doesn't do that you
wouldn't be
in larger bodies like this but have a
body positive brand okay that's why
[Music]
she's coming from an incredibly
privileged position which she seems to
have lost sight of last but not least
she's spewing this fat phobic hate in
2019 but she launched her good american
brand which was size inclusive in 2016.
how can you talk about people in larger
bodies like this but have a body
positive brand oh yeah that's why
because you see the money in the body
positive movement and you're trying to
cash in on it i can't stand people that
are like eating a bucket of like
haagen-dazs ice cream look i'm so fat
and like they won't work out they won't
change their diet they won't drink
cool
okay we're back yeah
okay so
um i know we touched on this a little
bit earlier but she said a lot in that
video and i'm just curious why don't we
go around everyone give me your initial
reaction to it
my thing is a message is true regardless
if a message is true then it's true
regardless of who said it so it doesn't
matter if she's done all those things or
if you know she paid for her body and
whatever what she said is still true if
you're complaining about being fat but
then you're still eating excessively
that's on you the same way if i was
broke but then choosing not to work i
couldn't complain
yeah i think um
i'm going to start by saying that i
agree with what chloe said um in the
video
and um i also believe that you know
i looked at the other woman i thought
she's doing it for likes i don't
actually think she believes what she's
saying and she's doing it to get a
reaction out of the audience so that's
what initially came out of me
um i mean obviously everyone now knows
how i feel about um like emotional
eating again i'm not going to harp on
about it but my initial feeling seeing
chloe saying those things actually made
me feel quite angry sorry angry
um
i i kind of get what you're saying about
the other woman probably maybe doesn't
agree she was making it purely for the
fact that it's a tick tock
but
i think she makes a good point at
everything the kardashians do she's
probably saying it because she feels
anger towards the kardashians not
necessarily the topic everything the
kardashians do
is about making money so
chloe probably doesn't really feel any
of those things i i don't think
what comes to mind after watching that
first talking to the mic first of all
chloe was always the bigger kardashian
let's just keep it wrong yeah is that
right she was always the bigger
kardashian so
part of me is thinking
maybe she gets to
speak on certain aspects when it comes
to the fat communion things like that
for that reason only but what i will say
is i hate this rhetoric this so typical
stereotypical rhetoric of like fat
people are just sitting around eating
haagen-dazs or ben and jerry's all day
just fitting away for themselves i hate
that so that's one thing i want to put
out there and i think thirdly
the last point she made which is that oh
what are they eating they're eating
something they listen they're eating
something but i just hate the rhetoric
that they're eating and they're just
swearing about it but they're not eating
celery which usually makes you lose
weight they could be eating celery and
crying that they fall so like i just
feel like it's a silly restoration
narrative or you know stereotype but
lastly my point would be you know she
said about the whole good america thing
she started the jeans company um good
american and
notably she's made it sort of like body
positive and you know in the campaign
ads they have sort of like why they say
women and things like that but it might
be a bit controversial because of what
i've said so far in the show but i
actually don't think because of that
she's not
allowed or informed to say what she said
weirdly enough i actually don't think
the two correlate i think i think she
can i don't know it's weird i actually
feel like she can just because she has a
brand that promotes body positivity and
inconsistent inclusivity of different
body types i don't think she can not say
the point that she said i don't know
it's a bit of a controversial one but
that was my initial reaction watching it
well firstly let me introduce myself
since i just came on a podcast my name
is apollo i'm 21. thank you for having
here here as well
uh my initial reaction was
[ __ ] leftist man i'm allowed to swear
right
leftists they're destroying the world
i won't lie the the
the mindsets and and the way that they
look at issues is is is is completely
wrong like
it seems that freedom of speech seems to
be an issue with with leftists um people
aren't allowed to voice their opinions
or only certain types of people are
allowed to voice their opinion however
when the opinion is
not fitting to their ideology
you're suddenly suddenly not allowed to
uh voice that
yeah
um
yeah i think
i find i've i find it i don't even i
don't think it's
genuine her reaction to chloe in terms
of i think she's just doing it for likes
man because
like you take a look at the woman and
she's in great shape she looks after
herself clearly um
so and i think yeah you're right the
kardashians are going to do it for money
you know i mean it doesn't surprise me
she was saying one thing in 2016 another
thing in 2019. i mean because money like
they say money is green right so if i if
i had merch and a bunch of fat people
wanted to buy my merch yeah i'm gonna
make the merch inclusive to fat people
because i want to make money exactly is
there anything wrong with wanting to
make money very cheeky of chloe actually
man she definitely was fat before so
it's very mad it's actually very mad at
her now that i think about but that's
what i say it doesn't if something is
true
it's true regardless of who says it so
yes she was packed before and yes she
probably had liposuctions and you know
worked on her body in terms of you know
on in with dr miami or something but
she's what she's saying is still true i
think going back to what the other woman
said with regards to the fat person
sitting on the sofa and eating and the
skinny person sitting on the sofa and
eating what she's failed to mention is
you know the per the skinny person
sitting on the sofa probably went to the
gym and he's probably going to the gym
again the next day and the next day so
it's all dependent on the context in
which you put it in there what's really
weird about that like
if i it's weird because you if you see
she said if you see a fat person sitting
in you know be past judgment if you see
a skinny person like oh yeah you take
care of yourself if you go to the gym if
i see a big person in there i'm like yo
go you man go you when i see someone in
shape doing it i'm like yeah
like i don't think anything but if i see
a big person in the gym i'm like
i'm like rooting for them because
they're like you know trying to make a
difference but not just that if i saw
someone who was anorexic you know not
eating and you know always just stopping
themselves from eating i would tell them
you probably shouldn't be doing that you
know it's let's let's not act as if
their problems are the same if i saw
someone who's obese not eaten i would
probably wouldn't be saying to them oh
that's bad you know people have
different issues and different solutions
say to them that that's bad you would
tell someone who's anorexic or maybe
suffering from bulimia like oh maybe you
should you know not not have that kind
of relationship with food why wouldn't
you tell an obese person
if someone who is obese is having
restrictions on their diet in order to
lose weight why would i tell them to
stop that
i was just interested to know because
you just appeared but that's what um
he's encouraging the solution yes eat
less
you know also i think he just said he
wouldn't sell that person
i do think a big problem is that there's
so many things in school about life in
general that we're not taught we talk
about i was speaking to somebody about
this the other day like we talk about
the most random things like how to turn
an acid into an alkaline like what the
[ __ ] who's ever going to need that but
are we ever taught about like intuitive
eating i think that's something that's
quite important when we were saying
earlier about parents who have obese
children
that then is something that those
children it's like learnt behavior and
that's going to become far more
difficult for them to
grow out of almost into adult life and
live
you know like as a healthy person
because they will have grown up eating a
certain type of way in certain types of
food i think that's something that
should be taught in school but in in low
income like in countries that are
poor right they don't get taught that in
schools they just do it
i don't i don't think that's an excuse
and also i went to communication
and
they even taught us that it's not so
hard to go to a private school anything
i just think as an adult you know if you
if you eat more you'll be fatter if you
eat less you'll be thinner just have a
problem with how cut and shut this is
guys i'll be so honest with you i i just
think that nothing is that black and
white in life but this is what this is
unfortunate
this is a woman this is this is a phrase
this is a phrase woman that women always
say on my show
because because no because i think women
were generally more empathetic than men
yeah and so i think we're always looking
for the exceptions and the butt but like
when it comes down to it like be
accountable for your results i'm all
about it and so and so if you're if
you're bigger it's because of a choice
that you made it's not because you
didn't get the right education right
it's not because you know you're not
informed about food we have the internet
you can google anything you want to
google it can't be a common pokemon but
this is like that you know it but it it
it is and that's that's the thing like
when we keep giving excuses to women
like it's it's worse on us in the long
run
because we're excusing bad behavior but
this is why i keep asking you
why is it that in countries where
there's famine they don't have this
issue and you you're not answering the
question because it is this black and
white exactly because there's family
what i'm so sorry you've been answering
that question
because there's famine bro that's why
but what does that mean because there's
no food to get so they can't eat there's
your answer so eating less tends to mean
that you lose weight right someone in
the conversation just said that a
deficit of calories yes so it is that
black and white because in the extremes
you see that so
clearly but here even even if you
even cause a lot of people will say
things like oh it's um if you have money
then you can afford the trainers you can
afford the good food or whatever but
nothing's stopping you from eating rice
eggs
it's cheap and i don't think it takes a
genius to figure out those are good
foods and i've i've been pretty
overweight at one point but you can you
can lose it yeah and so i'm like when i
was overweight i was like this is my own
damn fault and i ran a marathon to lose
it i mean i didn't have any excuses for
myself i mean
but that that helped you of course and
so offering excuses to other women hurts
them but what i'm saying is that not to
offer excuses and it's probably going to
tap into to what you're saying in terms
of
it's not always necessarily a choice
what i'm saying is
it's not as black and white as was
saying that you've got to look at the
root issue i'm not saying it it
minimizes the accountability or
responsibility in the how they
contributed to themselves putting on
weight what i'm saying is that look at
the root issue there might be a lack of
adequate education i'm not even really
saying the emotional thing like and
don't get me wrong i know where you're
coming from a bit and that's probably
from personal experience and that's why
you truly believe it might not be always
the case what i'm saying is that in life
there's always a root issue right
but the root the root issue could be
like a vacation yeah but the root the
root issue could just be a lack of self
control and eating good foods
so so i'll give you an example for for
me right so i used to have this issue
where i would get like stupid hungry
like i would be so hungry i just had
like a bottomless pit and i felt like i
couldn't figure it out but what i
figured out was i wasn't eating
nutrient-dense foods
yeah
right
but i found that out by googling
and researching it myself right because
okay that's that's what i'm saying like
i figured out that's why i i could eat
and eat and never be satisfied because i
didn't have the nutrients but then your
answer will essentially what i'm saying
no but i'm saying there's like right
like i'm big like i need to sort of do
something no but that's what i'm saying
what i'm saying is i didn't give myself
excuses but i didn't have a reason i
found out a reason but it was also a
lack of self-control and discipline but
there was a reason for you right right
right but but the reason like the reason
behind the reason like why did i get to
that place in the first place
that's what i'm no no i'm saying before
before the reason i was in the point
where i was eating foods that weren't
nutrient dense was a lack of
self-control right okay i love ice cream
you know what i mean
like i was and and you know a lot of the
foods that i was eating were like
microwavable foods right right so it was
a lack of self-control i was lazy i
didn't want to cook okay and and so but
that was me being lazy and taking
accountability for that gave me better
results right and so it's not kind to
bail out women for their bad decisions
because it gives them worse results okay
in the long run but coddling women i'm
using the word that you used in in that
sense
do you feel like it has better results
as well because i don't feel like the
tough laughing works of the matter sure
it's a short it's a it's a short-term
solution it's like a plot it's like
putting a plaster on you need to expose
the wound so it can stay aggressive
because thing is you do you have a son
or a daughter a son of a son okay so if
he
got really obese
right
okay but let's say he's 15 he's really
obese right yeah and he's obese because
of a justifiable reason in your eyes
okay yeah right you're just gonna let
him be obese
or you're gonna try and no but the thing
is there's a reason there's a reason
okay but no no no one's saying there
isn't a reason right all we're saying is
that you are in control of your weight
right and so
anybody who is big
it is down to the decision they're in
control
i'm not disputing that okay so we agree
then you know we listen that's the thing
we agree but my thing is maybe it's just
it's maybe it's the language we're using
that i'm fine
because i just know i agree because i
just feel like it's very cut and short
and that there's no gray area in what i
feel like you guys are are saying
concerning it it's very much your big
lose weight end off but i think that's
just not live the reason why
you can't you can say that like that
could that could be the the surface
level right right but it can be okay
well you are big there may be reasons
behind it justifiable reasons that you
understand let's look into that then and
then that's where our solution will lie
because that's no no no no no looking
for the reason that's the solution
that's not the solution exactly
one at a time please execution will be
in the reason but the idea right the
idea of being fat i understand it might
not be black and white right however you
can you can look for the reason it can
be whatever however the solution will
always be you probably need to eat less
like that's and that's what we're saying
that's what we're saying this is what
this is why i don't think we agree
because that's all i said if you're if
you're not eating you will lose weight
that's what i said if that was all you
said i wouldn't but that was the whole
point of that was the whole point of the
example with countries with famine i
just felt like you weren't giving space
for other factors no you made it sound
like you are big one plus one is two you
are big lose weight but
i think what we're saying is the factors
don't matter in the sense of in the
sense
no what i mean is the factors don't
matter in regards to what the solution
is exactly that's what we're saying i
disagree then i'm not disagreeing okay
because the fact is
the reason why the the weight problem
was created in the first place right and
it's true the statement as to you know
the statement of your fact you need to
lose weight is a true it's a good
statement right and and the and uh the
truth behind that is that you have to
find out why you got fat for example
with you you said you were lazy right
and even with you as you said with
hormones
with emotional
um eating and disorders right we've got
to look at what uh eating disorder
really is you're feeling some type of
way there's some sort of issues some
emotional issues anxiety whatever it is
probably caused from trauma or however
it's happened
and instead of dealing with it
the person is choosing to fill that void
and kind of stabilize themselves
did you hear that yeah
yeah so there's always a choice there
like you're feeling the emotions but you
have a choice to either address the
emotions or eat and stimulate yourself
and get fat well and all the solutions
are pretty much the same though it's
definitely eat healthy foods
eat less eat less calories exercise
that's my point you'll be comfortable in
your own skin but you know what it's
also do nothing and just stay fat
no but if you don't find the cause then
you don't have the the emotional uh
stimulate drive as to why to to to solve
it but you know why it's also a choice
because some people over eat right some
people over some people under eat it's
not i said there's a blanket thing that
people with that specific um ailment do
they don't just all overeat and so it is
a choice how you choose to you know you
decide to eat your feelings decide to go
to the gym you start to play games in
order to whatever that trauma was it's
still a
choice have to be at peace with the
decisions you make so what i mean by
that is if you overeat as an example and
you put on weight you have to be at
peace with the fact that you might not
be able to find that high attainable man
and you can't moan about that so you
just have to it's ownership and
accountability and i think that's where
the issue is this is accountability i
actually very much agree with you
because i don't want people to think
that i just hate fat people or anything
like that i'm not no no what i'm saying
is that we should put fat people in a
labor camp so we get free work and they
lose weight
what i'm actually saying is
i don't want people to
to think that that's what i'm saying
what i'm actually saying is
if you are fat
your decisions led to that that's all
i'm saying and you can't expect other
you can't expect the world to give you
understanding you just can't unfold the
people that it didn't lead to that i had
a friend right and i'm not gonna put
this business out here too tough but um
he had sort of a i think it was an auto
autoimmune disease or he had some sort
of disorder um some sort of disease and
the medication from that disease caused
him to put on an extreme amount of
weight
what would you say to him
did it make him obese
not obese okay then uh
and that's what we're talking about
there's not many people like that
so i was gonna say i know people that
have had like medical issues um but yeah
we're not talking about those people and
i think we just have to have
understanding for that right we're
talking about the gen no but that's the
exception
yeah we're talking about like a couple
of thousands in millions and billions of
people i mean maybe i've exaggerated
there but we're talking about the masses
like the 90 percent you know the rest
the rest of
also it's only those people die but
there's no there's no there's no
medication that makes you obese
i mean i never said he was obese but it
just made him i don't know retained
water or something okay
but there's a difference between putting
on weight right and then being
overweight so so i'm just trying to get
it clear that the main issue is that the
the presence of choice that's the main
thing
we're talking people who are saying that
could be obese if it was like i have a
reason no no no no no no no no no the
main the main issue is that we don't
hold women accountable and we coddle
them for poor choices right that's what
i know that's your right that's that's
the main issue and you know what's funny
pro like if this was any other context i
really wouldn't even disagree with you i
really wouldn't be having that internal
battle that i would be like yeah we do
we do we do even marketing
you know how certain products are
marketed it's it's
to
coddle women in a way on certain things
but i just feel like in this regard it's
just too
i feel like if i didn't take this stance
no one would and it'll just be too
simple but the thing is
that people should
should do so you're saying that uh
people are coddled mm-hmm what is the
solution i suppose from you what i would
like to see is to get rid of movements
like body positivity and stop putting
these women on a pedestal for being fat
that's what i would like to see
i'd like to see women actually being
honest with each other and stop telling
their fat friend that nothing's wrong
that's that's what i would like to see
are happy with themselves being listened
to but that's okay and that's about all
bodies out there for everyone to see and
say like oh like that's how i look or
even if body positivity isn't just about
size it's also about so on instagram for
example
i mean it's all still feels a little bit
fake but there are a lot more women who
are starting to post
themselves in angles and positions which
aren't as flattering and that as a woman
is is good to see because it's just a
reminder okay actually we don't all look
perfect every day like we i mean i think
it's just common sense like instagram is
for models
they're not real
it's still good to see because those
kinds of things are in your face every
single day
common sense isn't common i see roles
all the time on tick tock
and then and plus even victoria's secret
they're getting fat chicks in there now
fat shakes are coming in i see i see
more rolls thrown in my face all the
time i don't want to see that
i want to see the girl i can't be so i
can work out to be her
because that's what i want to see i see
[ __ ] as motivations
a lot of men have is when women say that
if you do not like fat women you are fat
phobic
that idea
i'm not scared of fat people i just
don't find black people
i think
i saw this thing on instagram that was
like it's selfish to be fat because
everyone has to look at you wow and i'm
not honestly
because when you're overweight you put
everyone like when i get on an airplane
and someone's overweight next to me like
that's putting me
that i have to deal with your poor
choices why do i have to deal with that
that goes against the liberal principle
of uh you know i forgot what's good but
you know your choice is not affecting
other people
yeah
yeah i know what you mean and even and
even if you do get overweight then
you're on the health then you go to the
hospital early right and the tax players
have to deal with your poor decisions
when did we become so intolerable
it's not intolerable it's it's that
it's that yeah it's
the number it's that you're making other
people deal with your poor choices and
if you want to if you want to be fat and
i don't have to deal with the
consequences fine fine that's totally
fine go do you but my issue is that
they're putting their insecurities on
men and saying like me like us look at
us no no we don't want models on the
cover of victoria's secret you have to
look at us what the [ __ ] we don't want
to look at you
and i wouldn't be i wouldn't be on i
wouldn't go up to victoria's secret and
say hey i think you should have six foot
gingers on the line
look at me look at me i should be the
beauty standard like what if i went what
if i went to all the modeling agencies
and said i should be the beauty standard
why don't i see girls that look just
like me
no no because that's
narcissistic narcissism i don't see
anyone going to college
i disagree and the reason i disagree
because going back to what we were
saying about khloe kardashian right it's
all about the benjamins right yes and i
think the stat was what 42 percent of
people are obese is what you're saying
earlier that's your target addressable
market so
by definition they should be on the
cover because it's more sales more money
it's all about shareholders
but it's
you're right it's women putting women
above men and that's that's what i'm
saying because 70 to 80 of consumer
buying decisions are made by women and
so i'm glad you said that because at the
end of the day it's not for the men it's
for the women and even the body
positivity movement is for the women
it's always about women oh do you have
any fat friends
i don't have many dudes
no no no i was like i don't really have
a lot of friends i talked to my family i
have 10 siblings
so i don't want to do i just hang out
with them to be honest
if any of your siblings are fat but
maybe
i think i think a big reason why this is
happening all of this body positivity is
happening now in this sense is because i
don't think historically women have ever
been sexually rejected by men
i don't think they ever have but i think
we live in times now where because sex
is given so freely
that
now there are top percent men
that will discriminate against certain
women which before sexually never
happened because sex wasn't moving this
food yeah ganges khan was just
i don't think that's why it is i
honestly think it all centers around
social media because there was never the
pressures of social media before so now
women are far more insecure than they
ever have been girlfriend
is true but no one's forcing you to be
on instagram in fact no they're not but
but
like social media has massively impacted
our culture and the way we live in you
know how people feel about themselves um
but i i think there's a reason
there's a reason why hey there's a
reason about it why body positivity is
only for women
yes it's not for men
and i don't see women complaining about
them it's not it's not for men
it's only for women because let me ask
you why do you think it's only for women
what is body positivity it's not for men
why do i think it's true why do you
think it's only why do you think it's
only encouraged for women not men
you said earlier that women are more and
empowered for example were more
emotional were more empathetic i think
it was the words that you used um so i
think i think i think it boils down to
that and i do think men are a lot
tougher on themselves
i think why are we maybe there's
biological reasons why don't women
support big men why don't we support big
men y'all don't support yourselves
you said women are more pathetic yeah
right so why are they not empathetic
towards the larger men i know my answer
even though i said it ingest it's the
truth you are
empathetic towards yourself
but we're not we're not talking about
why aren't you men i'm not talking about
i'm saying the reason lies in there why
should i feel that that's probably why
we're not so you're saying because men
are empathetic to big men that's why we
are i feel like perhaps the answer lies
in there i'm not entirely sure of course
but i feel like perhaps the answer lies
in there why isn't it
positive although i said earlier that i
would date a bigger man so no but i
don't think women are against male body
positivity but it's about
women understanding how it feels and
trying to like get together and build
each other up and say do you know what
bikini body is everybody like
that's what the yeah i would it's not
that but the reason i did positivity
i got to look at it like
women
i would i was overweight i wasn't
wearing a bikini i was like i don't
deserve it
sorry i got a question for the ladies
right
if you're at a beach right and you see a
fat man with his top off why are you
putting them like that
because it really it really matters
because the man's place are you going to
be okay with that yeah because i know i
don't want to see that and i'm a guy
like don't get around be like do your
thing but i can imagine it's not
appealing
for them to see nothing jiggling or
nothing
i don't think there's anything wrong
with that as long as he hasn't got
speedos on oh so there's caveats to it
okay
there's no
come on shut up you don't want to give
him a job
we are not you are not you are not
complaining about michael b jordan in
this video but genuine question any
question why isn't their wallet
positivity because
men out here we we have empathy for
other men who are broke facts we have
empathy empathy for them so i'm never
like why is it why is that not
why
there physically can't be positivity
towards a breakthrough but you see what
i'm saying
from women so if you want wallet
positivity bring it from the men no but
you guys are telling us to to to like
fat [ __ ] yeah i'm saying i don't know
but see here's here's the here's
here's here's here's the difference
though
women go to men and tell them what they
need to like men don't go to women and
tell them what they need to like
you don't see men going and shaming
women for not liking broke guys most
guys will say yeah don't date a bum like
what are you doing
but girls will go to guys and shame them
for not dating the things that matter to
them so they'll they'll have [ __ ]
shaming they'll have body positivity
yeah like all the things that men value
women [ __ ] on them for yep but can i
just say though with regards i'm
actually going to back the women here
and i'm
sounds like i'm going to make a little
bit of an excuse i think sometimes
females back each other up because when
they say it's out of um
it's not by choice something you've got
to look at like single mothers right who
are bringing up young families they
don't have time to go to the gym wait
but they made the choice to be a single
mother
no no okay okay who did you who did you
pick you need to have responsibility for
who you pick most girls know who they're
dating yeah they know who they agree
they know who they're sleeping with and
then they're mad that future didn't want
to stick around it's like you're dating
you slept with future you dated future
and now you're overweight because you
don't have time because of a choice you
made like it all goes back
of choice they made
but also sorry um
even when it comes to that you know a
single mother who doesn't have time to
go to the gym i'm someone who's very
much into my fitness and everything you
can intermittent fast and that doesn't
require money it doesn't require time it
doesn't require anything other than
discipline yeah and so if you're not
doing that that is on you
there are there are options you can
there are different avenues you can take
in order to lose weight you don't have
to go to the gym all the time you don't
have to be eating you know 200 calories
a day you can just intermittent fast and
you will lose weight but people aren't
doing that well also the point you said
about uh you know
fat people being deserving of love i
think obviously we will agree everyone's
deserving of love 100 too because you
know
at the end of the day all humans are all
suffering you know in some sort of way
we all have our battles that we're
fighting we're trying to overcome and so
forth right
but
um i think we're talking about desire
fat people are worthy of desire
like being worthy of my attraction my my
attraction doesn't even
switch on and that's the case and that's
why i said no one's entitled to a
partner no one is actually entitled to
have a partner man or woman it doesn't
matter yeah
i'm not entitled to friends if i'm the
biggest [ __ ] here no one's going to
like me it's just a fact i can't be
saying why don't people like me you know
it's you can't be saying that's not what
to do you don't see me complaining i
don't know
just because i say friends doesn't mean
i'm just you know using that to show you
what i mean you know i want to put out
there that um you said that everyone's
entitled to love and my idea is i don't
think i think women and children are
entitled to unconditional love i don't
think men are men have to earn it
because
a man's role in psy is to earn his love
he has to earn something like if he's
not bringing something to the table
it's you as a woman will find it hard to
love i don't disagree but just take it a
step back though the love thing like
i'mma just really say it now like i just
believe as a basis that all human beings
like that's so mad what you just said
that women and children oh i'm your mom
yes you know and men just have to keep
grinding out here to get lost that's
reality i'll give you an example if
when the titanic was [ __ ] sinking right
who got off first but that's the women
and the children that's not that's that
that's the women can procreate i'm not
talking what are you talking about a man
a man can populate an island full of
women where a woman can only procreate
once for nine months so if we're gonna
go off of procreation then the men
should be on the boats because they can
populate more than women okay fair
enough but
we're talking about who's deserving of
love and things the titanic it was
survival no no but i'm saying i'm i'm
sorry we don't take it again but it goes
back to human nature that's all it is
yeah that's what it's human nature that
men understand that they need to stay
back and fight whatever is going on or
and i think that's why your life is a
good at risk
i think basically he's trying to say
that in society men are intrinsically
valued less
i don't disagree but we're talking about
love yeah and so like a man can she can
only really be loved if you provide
something
outside so it's conditional it's of
course yes yes yeah and that's that's
the difference between men and women is
women love conditionally men don't
like men can just love a girl that's
doing nothing right and he can fall head
over heels in love with a girl that's
just like there she's beautiful she's
feminine she's pretty yeah and she she's
a good mother right where a man has to
be something so he has to have a good
job he has to be over a certain height
he has to be over a certain level of
looks but they're okay so are you saying
that there are women that won't invest
solely
in tears into a broken heart if a man if
a
if a man is fat one one out of one out
of three men under 30 either haven't had
sex in the last year or are virgins if a
man is fat and broke nobody's dating her
there's always somebody that will date a
woman
if a girl is overweight like even 600
pound life half of them had boyfriends
yeah yeah
and so there is there is always a guy
willing to date a girl but there is not
always a girl willing to date a guy oh i
don't know i don't know
because i'm invested in men that i
usually those guys are somewhat
attractive yeah i have friends that have
dated guys that are bums right yeah
because but
they're either yeah they have something
right they're usually somewhat
attractive and if they're not crazy
attractive they have game they're a good
sweet talker they they have something
yeah but it's just not the same for men
and for women because men have to be
women just are
women a woman can be 18
beautiful and she has her pick of men
yeah man turns 18. did you guys have
ladies lining up for you the day you
turned 18.
you all know what to do if you want not
to be different y'all the gatekeepers
changing no
no women but this you're wrong again
it's like women women are the
gatekeepers of sex and sex tense in 2022
tends to come before relationships we've
already sort of ironed out that we're
gonna we're gonna disagree with that
that that's i'm gonna disagree with you
i think that's okay for you to believe
that but what i'm saying is from my
experiences in my neck of the woods and
how i have engaged with life i've come
to understand that certain things
whether consciously subconsciously that
we
find ourselves abiding by whether
unspoken are things that men have woven
but do you know why that's wrong
sorry when it comes to dating i'm not
talking about any other recipes in life
do you know why that's wrong because
there was more women than men and yet
it's still
men that a lot of men that aren't
getting any form of access okay and so
it shows you that it's women that are
dictating how the market what the market
wants right not men okay so how can you
make that state how can you make those
two statements right whilst you're
saying okay right now before from my
neck of the woods yes
that's what i said
it's because it's because she's looking
at a small percentage of men she's not
taking men by and large she's she's just
looking at the small percentage of men
and thinking that's all as humans we
speak from experience
i mean you can you can influence
to speak but this is the thing like
women don't and this is something i had
to understand too because when i first
heard the stat one in three men haven't
had sex in the past year i was like what
men are you talking to like
the men that i know they're getting hoes
you're not like they're
they're
but there is a whole group of men that
you don't even see you don't see the guy
that works at mcdonald's invisible you
don't see the guy that is taking your
order
you don't see them you see the guy
that's six foot and handsome that's who
you're looking at and it's me too right
i'm just i'm just being honest me too
and it's not something we intentionally
do but there's just a class of men that
really aren't seen yeah i've got two
questions please can ask two questions
yeah so
in your do you have male friends is the
first question
so let's say you've got 10 male friends
10 female friends
how many of your male friends are saying
oh yeah you know i'm seeing this girl
but i'm gonna make her wait
and how many of your female friends are
saying oh i got a guy i want to make him
wait
who's making who wait i mean we've grown
but i know where you're going with this
so obviously women are more likely to do
the 90 day rule and you know stuff like
that as opposed to more likely or are
doing it
okay because that's what we're saying
basically
they have the power women have the power
it's a woman who makes man you know a
woman
is the one that
you know uh inspires a man to either be
great or or be lesser a woman can take a
great man and make him bad and a woman
can take a good man wait a bad man and
make him good yeah i disagree because
you know i intrinsically want to do well
for myself not because of a woman but
what i'm saying is that the multiplying
effect of woman like if you if you are a
successful man and you marry a bad wife
a woman no no no i i agree that yeah a
bad woman can drag you down the same way
a bad man can drag down a little good
same with someone who's like
someone with someone same with the
you know a man who's quite low but he's
ambitious and he has a vision but he's
still low you know in terms of uh
society uh economically and whatnot and
a woman like for example i don't know
about his relationship but kendrick
lamar and his and his wife she seems to
be a writer who's been there from day
one and she really pushed him to you
know be greater so it goes both ways
yeah i was gonna ask you a question
actually to both of you
out of 50 guys who maybe would approach
you
right maybe give you a look at the club
at a bar
or maybe actually try and come talk to
you out 50 guys how many of them would
you give a chance on it gonna go on an
actual date with that you look at them
my number okay go natural day as in like
so you look at me look at them and go oh
i like the vibe and energy of you enough
that yeah i'll go on a date with you i
have 50 guys
guess about three about three how about
you
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
i'm anti brother do you know what i
would have said free i'm not gonna lie
so maybe i gotta say five then so you
know how you're saying you know you know
how you're saying that
basically yeah fair enough so you know
how you're saying like you're basing
your opinion based on your experience
so out of 50 guys there's 45 of them
that you're not experiencing because
you've rejected them right right so all
of your experience is coming from the
top five or ten percent of guys and you
would probably still friend zone one or
two though yeah
and then and then the irony is yeah 50
guys this is the reality the same five
guys you will give a chance at the same
five guys she will give a chance
probably not
because i dated five foot seven guys she
didn't date in the five years i know but
what i'm trying to say is like it's it's
uh it's like the crossover is the it's a
small pool of guys who are getting the
majority of opportunity there may be
like one or two that's more your type
that you wouldn't choose and vice versa
yeah but i'm trying to say like if
you're taking a pool of men the kind of
men that you go oh actually yeah you
bring this this this this all these
things that i like yeah right because we
know women have higher standards fair
enough that's just the way it is right
it's just the way it is
the majority of men don't fit all of
those standards so what's you know and
i'm not trying to be able what's the
point the problem i think the point is
it's like i have a guy at your you're
using you'll gain your opinion yeah you
said from your experience but i said
that yeah yeah
oh so you're saying that you're saying
that there is i'm making like a blanket
statement i'm just understanding that
he's saying the experience you have is
with a small percentage of men exactly
so your experience isn't very
representative because you're not like
the men you deal no i'm not saying
you're disagreeing he's just furthering
the point yeah and i think i think the
problem we're having is because we're
talking about
the population in general you're talking
about very specific anecdotal evidence
i'm not saying an inductive evidence is
irrelevant however when we're talking
about the wider society your anecdotal
evidence is wrong it's wrong to the
wider society so what's your name again
jesse jesse i feel like you um
you're someone who's very pragmatic in
that sense and it has to be either yes
or no or on or off yes and i think
that's why we're always going to sort of
butt heads on this specific argument
find me on instagram and i'ma tell you
out of what i just said what is wrong
though because that that's that's what
i'm struggling to understand right now
i'm saying that your
anecdotal evidence is wrong um when
applied to
um the entire population
oh sorry i know you can't answer sorry
but sorry i i'm just going to say
something that's slightly different
anyway something i find really
interesting is how different things are
in terms of not just relationship people
committing to
each other men and women
obesity rate is so different depending
on where you're from and where you live
like i'm not from london i'm from
coventry
and if i compare
the girls that i know who still live in
coventry
the life that they have compared to
girls in london it is so different and
even if you look at obviously like the
stats of obesity in america
how can that be so different to the rest
of the world
well i would say that our food is worse
and and so that's a factor but you can
still make good choices and not eat the
food that is bad and eat more the food
that's good but again so and for example
in london i'm now far more active even
just going from a to b then i would be
in coventry like that's just a given
therefore it probably is
um i i don't know that this is true but
i would suspect that people are thinner
in london than they are in other areas
of the country the same with america
like in new york
you're probably going to get people the
majority of people are thinner than they
are outside in other areas of america
and again
something that you said earlier i can't
remember exactly what it was but it was
about
men
choosing not to commit because women
women were sleeping around a bit uh so
what uh what i was saying was that
because sex is more easily accessible
especially for
you know the percentage of men who have
all the options
um
it's easier for them to
reject
unless desirable women so we're taking
women who are bigger because they're
getting access to the more desirable
women a lot more easier was back in the
day
right because it was kind of sex outside
of marriage and commitment was taboo
they wouldn't be getting that sexual
attention from the from multiple
desirable women
so then it was easier for women who
weren't as desirable to him
to get sex from him because he wasn't
getting it multiple from desirable does
that make sense yeah but have you
thought that that could be to do with
the fact that men and women now have far
more options than they ever did before i
would say that we're constantly thinking
oh like there's something better a small
percentage of that that's a good point
but yeah i would demand have all the
options where most of them have all the
options but i think most men now have
more options than they ever did no
actually
is and i'll give you this example right
it's
it
um
like where do you say you grow up
coventry coventry like so for example if
you take if you take back in the day the
girl from a small english village where
social media internet wasn't a thing
right the pool of men she would choose
were the men from her village yeah right
now because of social media and the
thing is the chances are she would
choose a nice average man right now
because of social media dating apps the
internet
she can connect with the hot shot lawyer
from london the basketball player from
paris the producer from l.a yeah so that
average guys in her circles are looking
pretty weak compared to the
opportunities that she has so what's
actually happened is
for the average man he's actually got
little to zero options because women now
have access to high value men and high
value men now have access to multiple
women
does that make sense yeah on top of that
makes sense on top of that back in the
day women sort of knew that because they
can't
necessarily they don't tend to
necessarily work they needed a man to
get through life
nowadays where women have more money
to them it's like well i don't want i'd
rather have a man who earns the same or
more than me women would rather be
homeless than marry a betta and you can
see this because they interviewed
homeless women and a lot of them had men
they could have settled down with
and they left most of them
because they would literally rather be
on the streets than marry a guy they
view as beta yeah basically what's
happened is the necessity for men in a
woman's life has
decreased
right
which means right which is just the way
it is i don't think it's unfair or like
it's just the way it is which means that
she can afford to be even more picky
today because she doesn't need a man to
support her financially she can earn her
own money she can get her own place she
could drive her all of that which is
great
but the byproduct of that is that it
means that if more women have become
picky it means the power has gone
all to the top percentage of men which
most of the women want and that's why
you see 50 of women being single and
childless over 30 and the least happy
group of women is 45 and childless that
make over like 50 000 a year
and so it's like
we gas women up and this is part of body
positivity we gas women up to think
they're hotter than they are so they're
sleeping with guys that are out of their
league thinking they're going to commit
to them but they're never going to
and so then these girls think they're on
this level but they're not really on
this level they're really average and
then they hit 30 35 and they still won't
settle even though that's their level
and you know how you're saying about how
um you know
you came to london it seems like
everybody's in like do you say everyone
was like in much like really fear or in
better shape compared to commentary and
stuff yeah yeah yeah yeah i think
that goes back to what we're saying a
big part of that is because of
competition because london is a very
densely populated area
right and because there's a lot of
opportunities a lot of people who want
to make it big and whatever it is right
it's just dating career whatever you go
to one of these major cities but that's
where the competition is most fierce
so if you're gonna survive let alone get
ahead you need to be competitive in that
sense i just finished doing a show in um
in in strasbourg in france
and at the gym there all the girls
right were in incredible shape and all
the guys were incredible shape more so
than
east london here right
and it's because they're all competing
for each other
everybody's competing the higher the
competition the more we have to raise
our standards in order to play the game
but why would their competition be any
higher than anywhere in the uk
well i think in that particular one
there's some baddies there
i think because there were um there was
um it's a there was a major uni campus
there so like a third of the population
of the city were like
university students do you know i mean
strasbourg is in germany right uh it's
actually in france
france
the german people are very uh uh
what's up the ethnicity the the
population are they mostly german or
french
uh they're most they're mostly french
but strasbourg used to be part of
germany i used to be a party because i
would say that the work ethic of the
german people was very
very strong
yeah yeah yeah the thing is true so i'm
um belgian and you know over there in
those parts of europe the culture is
very different so i i was there till i
got till i i used to go back quite often
i did not see a fat person it's just the
culture there is just to you know be
that way so it makes sense that you went
to the gym even if girls can go to the
gym chances are a lot of them are very
thin so it's just the culture
when it comes down to it if you're if
you're fat you're unhealthy yeah and if
you're unhealthy you have less value
i'm going to take a second and read some
super chats so
guys as you know
we are trying to get ish a camera yes
ma'am you want to see what ish looks
like let's go get him a camera on top of
that guys like the video i think we were
close to a thousand likes last time i
checked so oh no we're at a thousand so
why don't we try to get a thousand two
hundred likes can we do that i think we
can do that for sure um so let's read
the super chats these super chats are
going towards ish's camera and some
other studio updates so send money
because it's really important to the
quality of the show if you want like you
can also watch for free but
okay vital46 lol i'm one of those
invisible men i'm chilling and working
my routine average 72k a year cheap
looking car and have fairly good savings
account most girls think i'm a good guy
and ask why i'm single simply too
awesome that's like the biggest insult
like why are you single but you could
date me exactly
simply too awesome scientifically men
are more sympathetic than our women are
more sympathetic than men men are more
empathetic than women this is because
they need to understand themselves and
women sing fred that's narcissism pearl
for the queen for the modern woman's
ideal mind i've given you like 17 today
hon thank you i rarely super because
that's essentially one hour of work hope
that helps with the mic it does
appreciate you
homie clicks why
wait why are having why does having fat
friends have to do with the conversation
don't change the goal post rusty fuel
fat lowers the gdp it costs taxpayers
medical expenses that's what i'd be
saying um semaine tagan
would the girls date a drug addict
that's like a functioning coke head
considering that's also an emotional
addiction that's a good question alistar
horton body positivity is about a lack
of personal standards shall i say
um
alastair horton again ask yourself which
is kinder to give someone the harsh
truth and deal with the problem or go
protect their ego and deny that the
problem's that bad dragon stallion one
zero zero one for the woman on the couch
if you put out kfc mcdonald's and ha
healthy meals which do you think large
people would reach for first the junk
food gennaro turs
gennaro lanters sell them an xxl t-shirt
motivate them to lose weight by telling
them the painful truth then sell them
another teacher
another t-shirt in a future small size
david acts western society is following
a woman's lead which has led us to this
place women will forever complain we
already know this boy type did my man on
the left just change ethnicities
aj
thesis
guys sometimes when we have too many
guests we rotate them in and out
sometimes
aj thesis people say beauty at any size
and it's not their fault instead of
giving them the information to lead a
healthy lifestyle the only person who
gave
who got me into this was me and i have
to get myself but out sam sampson
simpson
can you imagine spending the rest of
your life being someone that will go
this far to be right pop the popcorn
boys and enjoy the decline lazy artist
if you're a member you already saw ash's
tall self um
wait wait hold on yeah man
okay he's six seven he's six seven
changes every stream
i don't know what he was he was um
okay in a aj thesis in 19 in 19 years
old and have struggled with obesity for
the last four years being depressed
doesn't mean that you're not accountable
for the weight you gained um
sing oh gosh it's pronounced sig freed
sorry i forgive you pearl look sometimes
these names uh marcus moore sorry just
remind everyone that we saw ish on the
24 hour live livestream let me refresh
it real quick
and just to make sure there's no other
ones is sure being baited out today
honestly
we have beef everyone's wondering oh
yeah guys if you've watched two or more
of my videos and you don't subscribe we
have beef like come on a subscription is
free a like is free if you can't donate
subscribe i know a bunch of you being
here ghost watching and it's not cool
it's not cool
um okay that is all the super chat so i
think i'm gonna close out the show
so
um why don't we go around everyone say
any final thoughts you have so if you
there's something someone in the
comments you want to make your piece
with
say it now and then tell the people
where they can find you on social media
and yeah that's it
um final thoughts i really like the show
as far as i mean i love it um
if you're big whether it's man or woman
it's on you and you can lose weight
there's no other excuses
um you can find me on youtube and tick
tock uh my name is jesse praise on both
um
yeah i make finance content some of this
content and also gym content so if
you're trying to lose weight make sure
you're watching but yeah
i want to start by saying that first of
all i'm a lover of all all creeds shapes
and sizes but ultimately um people need
to be accountable for themselves and
their friends ultimately like are you a
true friend if you're letting somebody
damage themselves so don't be afraid to
um have that hard conversation because
ultimately it will lead to long-term
prosperity
um in terms of where you can find me on
socials at vibes and tribes uh yeah got
a travel podcast and a bit of a life
lifestyle podcast where i give career
advice and yeah neat tips and tricks to
help people progress in their careers
uh so my closing statement just in
response to one of the super chats the
reason i asked pearl if she had any fat
friends was because i was just generally
intrigued to know
if this is a conversation that she has
had with them and how they felt about it
and responded to it but
she said she doesn't have any friends
yeah otherwise my closing statement is
that it doesn't matter what size you are
you deserve to be loved and you look
amazing so
um yeah you can find me on instagram if
you've listened before when i was on
here at elle gray and also at gossip
station podcast
my closing statements um i really
enjoyed the show
just to respond to your question about
commitment and especially uh linking
that back to fat women
um
i think inherently men feel that fat
women are usually promiscuous and
uh as a man
uh giving commitment to someone that i
know is promiscuous is uh it's kind of
an l
um that's part of the reason i wear uh
virginity rocks because of you know
i i do think that you know the concept
of virginity is something that could be
brought back to
promote
uh healthy families and healthy
relationships and i think it's important
to let people know that uh there are
alternative lifestyles um
you can find me on the zcourse.world
i sound engineer i do all that good [ __ ]
thanks
final thoughts
it's kind of humorous i'm ending with
this because you're supposed to start
with it but in socratic debates you're
supposed to define the the terms that
you're going to be using within the
debate so that everyone's on the same
page and you know the
the i looked up the word privilege
before i got in here and the definition
of the word is
uh the benefit
uh or right or
uh that that someone has
and someone else doesn't have pretty
much along the lines so there is
there is a
skinny privilege or thin privilege
whatever you want to call it however
hey that's just nature man i love y'all
but don't be fat [ __ ] go work out go to
the gym be successful i'm saying don't
don't don't waste your life doing stupid
[ __ ]
and i think it was our nightingale was
it uh that gave the definition of
success as being army you told me i'm
not sure if it's something i think it
was dale carnegie maybe yeah maybe one
of those i'm not sure but he said that
the definition of success is
um having a goal and being in working so
you're progressing towards that goal so
you know for fat people out there just
set the goal that you want to be healthy
and and start working towards that
finding the root cause and whatnot and
you know i'm saying be on your way
young tate
honestly
um final thoughts
um understanding that
certain people may be overweight because
of reasons we can have compassion for
um but we should see that
your weight being in your control um as
a good thing because it shows that you
are in
power of
what you experience and you are
empowered over your life you are not
um controlled by
anything and recognizing that you have
agency over your life should be
empowering it shouldn't be um something
you want to relinquish control over
things that
you know have negative impacts on you um
so yeah and you you know you can find me
on instagram at kit is me
and i have a youtube channel called stay
slick with kit when i talk all things
dating
oh yeah i forgot to add my instagram
yeah
apollo barn spell a p o double l o b
double a n
robot
uh if there's anything i want to say is
going to be the dating market would be a
lot more pleasurable to be in um if
both genders male and female
um
realize what the opposite sex wants and
got themselves to a position where
they're more attracted to the opposite
sex as opposed to trying to pit each
other against themselves trying to force
people to
uh force men to like you when you're not
say attractive to where you are so it
does take work it does take perseverance
and nobody gets anywhere in life by
being lazy and being forcing people to
like them in the position they're at
where they're when they're putting in
the uh the work to get to where they
need to be
um
so yeah it's not a war out here it
should be you know all peace
i'm finding it so hard not to start this
debate again
i couldn't disagree more with a lot of
those things oh wow well well it's okay
next show tonight we can we can do
another i'll be hobbies we can we can do
another whales episode we we love we
love talking about the whales here yeah
i just want to plug my social media and
so
uh instagram i don't know youtube
regular guys so i'm uh ife dot
underscore a
um that's my instagram page so yeah
follow me on that
okay y'all thank you so much for the
super chats this
this show thank you so much for watching
we could not do this show without you
guys you guys are so important to the
growth of the show you guys have helped
us get 80 000 subscribers in the month
of june
how crazy is that
so guys subscribe if you haven't already
like the video on your way out and we
will talk to you next time bye
deuces
and that's a wrap